tada what's up happy wednesday you guys
yeah
got good drinks tonight yeah these are
delicious i mean
it might be dangerous because i might be
like sucking them down really quickly
i went to the liquor store to go re-spy
on the damn booze we kind of went on a
on a pinnacle vodka kick got some of
that
you know last week i got some of that uh
whipped cream vodka was mixed with
orange juice to make creamsicle i had
some cherry as well yeah the cherry was
right that was good
but then i looked over there and it had
coconut vodka
and i was like oh [ __ ] man that'd be
really good that'd be really good in
that uh pineapple mix an apple juice
yeah
it's actually pineapple nectar okay and
uh
because he can get that stuff for i
guess his room i don't know where it's
from honduras or something
um you can get a big old thing of juice
for like a dollar
it's good too yeah it's uh what's that
brand
oh [ __ ] i forgot i can see the lake
but that's spain yeah so it's not that
one it's the other one i forgot what it
was called
anyway man that [ __ ] is good man it is
really good
pinnacle mechanical coconut vodka
and pineapple juice with ice yeah man
it's really good i'm trying to think of
what else that would go with
coca-cola yeah probably
a little bit of lime juice in there
something
do they have a coke that has like a lime
what the [ __ ] am i thinking of
i think they did who's getting something
i mean isn't coconut lime good together
no yeah it's like a thai flavor yeah
yeah see what everybody's doing
coconut peanut butter got david in there
matt's in there
oracle mrs evans already party
that's another notification hands in
there tammy
t's in there she's going yo yo yo happy
wednesday uh-oh here comes spooky oh so
you want to throw it in
trouble bee's nest in there
gonna send bee's nest bunch of shirts so
we got we got some extra large
yeah i just did a big i just ordered uh
a big
shipment of 75 blank shirts and i still
have some
yeah it's just i was running out of some
sizes yeah so i had to get like a whole
bunch a whole bunch of new blank ones
yeah and then we'll do some new designs
and slap them on there
evidently she's uh t says she just got
done watching justice league
i heard i keep hearing it's good she got
burned out on comic book stuff she
hasn't
she forgot to see red son it's son like
s-o-n not s-u-m
but she did watch empty man she loved it
yeah empty man was good it was really
good yeah we watched that last night
yeah empty man was kind of like uh kind
of like a cronenberg flick
well i kind of liked because i you know
somebody a couple people had recommended
it to us and i had been
seeing like some buzz about it like a
lot of the horror review shows and [ __ ]
that i saw like i'd seen that a bunch of
them had reviewed it
and it looked like from the expressions
in the thumbnail that they were really
digging it and stuff and i was just kind
of like well i can't watch any of the
videos because i don't want to ruin the
movie
uh but i did want to get around to
watching it what i liked about it and i
won't spoil it for people because i
think it's better to go into it not
really knowing where it's going because
i didn't and so i thought that was like
really cool
but i i will say that i did like how it
started out as kind of like one thing
because the description says something
about like an urban legend which it does
have that in it
but then it kind of goes off in
unexpected
directions yeah like you said it has a
little bit of a cronenbergie kind of
thing has a little bit of a cosmic
horror kind of thing
but that's all um what's she doing
what's she doing is she laying on her
yeah shit's ridiculous
she's laying on her back in her in the
running position with her head looking
up
i wish i could put the camera on there i
mean you could but it might like
she's just like ridiculous i think she
does trip
she does that i think is because every
time she does that like we react to it
like
we laugh at her so she knows that that
gets attention she's like look i'm being
cute
yeah she knows what it does she knows
what it does i mean because she did that
to me the other day she just did it like
right in the middle of the floor
she attacked my rucksack tries to
[ __ ] tear up on it would it come out
of the shower because she doesn't have a
towel
and if she does that then i'll throw the
towel on
she wants to [ __ ] wrestle constantly
she loves towels and the whole
you coming out of the you coming out of
the shower with a towel she runs into
we got a walk-in closet with all the
[ __ ] she goes in the walk-in closet
she's
it's on now it's on she starts doing
stuff that's bad
because you can't really punish her yeah
i
mean
she loves to wrestle
she pretends like it's a huge epic fight
like a big show that's like her favorite
thing
seriously well that's the thing you get
out of the shower like even before you
get out of the shower when she's
someone's
in the shower yeah she'll like you'll
see her like go
like by the shower and she'll go yeah
get into position and then she goes in
the closet and waits looks ridiculous
it's [ __ ] funny yeah she said she
likes to wrestle with you like with the
towel when i go in there she's like mama
mama
yeah she wants you she wants me to like
sit down in the on the closet floor
and she like lays up against my she's
legs
right now oh is she can you see her no
she's walked away
oh okay she's like nope now i'm all like
self-conscious
so she's like laying back there all day
cool
she was [ __ ] with spock a few minutes
ago before we turned the show on
oh my god she's like so [ __ ] funny
um yeah that i was going to talk i was
going to talk a little bit about
path kitty have i told have i told the
saga of path kitty
on the show yet i don't know i don't
remember if i i thought i remember like
mentioning it but when uh the path that
i walk on
there is this kitty that is always kind
of sitting out there
like by the bushes or on the path or
whatever i'm pretty sure it belongs to
there's like a house and it's behind
like this high wooden fence but there's
a hole in the fence so
you know the cat can get out and they
have chickens too so sometimes the
chickens get out
but um so this cat has just been like
kept coming out and i keep seeing her or
him i'm pretty sure it's her
and um so a couple days ago i got kind
of like i was like i wonder if the
kitty's like really friend like she
doesn't like run away from people or
anything like that she either just like
ignores them or just kind of sits there
looking at you
and so i stopped next to her one day and
i was like hey kitty
and the kitty like looked up at me and
went so i bent down and started petting
and she was like all right i'm dealing
with this
and then like she did that for a long
time and then there was this other
there's this other woman that's always
like jogging
on the path i see her all the time and
she stopped and she was telling me about
she's like
she was petting the cat too and she's
like man i see this cat like every day
and
i have six cats and all this other stuff
so we were talking about that
and then i keep seeing this cat like
pretty much every day
and then today um the
the cat was sitting like in the middle
of the path and it was like watching me
it was like watching me as i walked up
and then i was walking up and then the
cat like came walking up to me i was
like
and i was like hey what's up and i was
petting the cat the cat is just like
swishing around my legs and stuff like
hey
you're my friend you're my friend and
then i noticed that
the cat is she looks okay like she looks
healthy
but from patner she seems a little
skinny not like starving
skinny but she's not getting she's
trying to say she wants to take the cat
she wants to take and her hair is she's
like a long haired cat she's a little
bit like beijing and her hair is kind of
matted
and even that other woman that stopped
she stopped today too when we were
talking about the cats and she said the
same thing
yeah i'm trying to tell her you don't
mess with it it's not your cat it's a
barn cat i know
that's a barn cat there's a barn right
there tempting with horses and cows
yeah it's like a little farm yeah we've
had lots of barn cats over
over the top you know uh especially when
my mom was deep in the horse business we
have barn cats you can't take them out
of the barn that's
where they live they live in a barn they
[ __ ] track down all the mice and the
rats and
the only thing that was kind of bad
about is in the era that you're in it
was hard for a barn cat usually didn't
make it to six or seven years
because uh eagles got them there's lots
of [ __ ] bald eagles in florida the
eagles get them
well you assume the eagles get them you
just don't find them
look at that cat go when you'd see
eagles all around you know
we just assumed the eagles were getting
them but um
you know they make mistake of going out
into an open field you know it's
that's death yeah that's where that's
where the eagles are looking
in those open fields got to stay up
around the bar and stay
keep overhead cover you know but um
that's a barn cat if you take it they'll
just buy another one
yeah you know what i mean like we brush
her hair though
because her hair just seems kind of
matted it's not real bad but it's just
like yeah i was thinking about that i
think tomorrow
tomorrow i'm going to take some treats
down with me and maybe a comb
you could put you could take a little
bowl with you put the treats in a bowl
and put them by the by the little exit
where she comes out of the yeah because
there's a little there's like a little
thing with a little bench right there
right
yeah yeah and she doesn't go far she's
always like i don't see her every day i
see her most days
but if i see her she's always in that
same exact area
like right there by that house and by
the fence
yeah and right by the bench yeah oracle
knows what the deal is [ __ ] the
husband's grandparents have barn cats
it's a working animal yeah yeah
i just feel bad and i wish somebody
would brush her hair that's all yeah and
that's somebody and she seems a little
skinny
so like i said i think maybe tomorrow
if i go for a walk tomorrow i'll take
some treats with me and then see because
for a while like i was you know petting
the cat for a while and then i had to go
and i was like and i walked and she like
walked alongside me for like a really
long time i'm like hey where are we
going you came
with me because she like kept going i
was like okay so you're just gonna
follow me home
i was going away from the house though i
was yeah they like being barn cats or
farm cats they like that
that's that's a that's a good life for a
cat i mean they have shelter
they go in the barn yeah that's true
they're getting fed all the time
you know they're just they just live
outside
i just you know you know how i am though
because i was talking to that lady and
she was just if you want to call the
barn outside because the barn isn't
really outside
yeah it's got a roof you know and that's
actually a pretty nice
yeah it's a nice place yeah they have um
a couple cows they have some chickens
they have a couple of horses
and i don't know how many acres it is
but it's like the house is nice and they
have like a really really nice
little red bar it looks like the classic
little red barn yeah you know what i
mean it's
like right by the fence so i'm guessing
she probably lives in there because like
i said i don't think she lives inside
because nobody brushes her
but you know as you know the lady was
like telling me today she's like you
want to take that kitty home don't you
and i was like yeah i kind of do
but i know i better not
you know what i mean it's like she's not
wearing a collar or anything but still i
don't know
this is why we always put a collar on
pookie when she goes out in the backyard
just in case somebody gets
ideas like look at this cute little
kitty i'm just gonna take her
so you know i know how that is
all right so what uh
what do you have to say thomas i have
anything to say
yeah last week jenny wanted to adopt the
gray kitty this week the barn kid yeah i
want to i want to adopt all the kitties
yeah
i'm not sure i'm not sure who who that
other gray kitty belongs to the one that
is
that yeah the one that is pookie's
friend that one comes and goes
which tells me that's in the house that
cat's coming from a house probably yeah
and that kid that cat looks pretty well
cared for
she's kind of chubby so somebody was
asking earlier on
i know we got to get on a subject
because a lot of people don't want to
hear about cats even though cats are the
most popular
on youtube chat videos and can't stop
watching the [ __ ] cat videos
and i get mad you know my testosterone
says stop watching the [ __ ] kitty
videos what
it's just there's nothing wrong with
anybody i'm just saying there's a
certain amount of just
i saw one yesterday kitty intolerance of
a little
of a little girl kitty named nathan that
that like to swim in that
starts taking you down a sentimental
path you don't want to go that way
too far down that sentimental path why
not you might turn into a woman you
might turn into a woman
i might lower your you might you might
grow a vagina
might do something like that there's
nothing i stop anabolic process there's
nothing inherently feminine about liking
cats thomas
[Laughter]
you know you love pookie right yeah of
course let me tell my story i'm trying
to tell stories you know
i'm an entertainer okay i'm trying to
entertain
you're trying to get reason out of me
when i'm entertaining
and reason is not is not entertaining
[Laughter]
when have you seen an action movie that
was reasonable when have you seen
when have you seen an entertaining movie
that was reasonable all that shit's
unreasonable
if the shit's reasonable it's realistic
it's realistic it's [ __ ] boring
so i'm just trying to tell stories okay
and entertain
people that pay us money yeah to for us
to help them [ __ ] well i was being
entertained
that you were gonna i said that you were
gonna grow a vagina that's pretty
entertaining
some new [ __ ] with the ufos okay yeah
why is everybody asking you about asking
about ufos
now does anybody know what the hell that
said because i didn't have time to last
i heard that
they're they're going to release some
more ufo stuff that they know more
or that they have more evidence uh that
they
haven't really talked about but it's
becoming declassified
you know we're talking about evidence
that came from fighter pilots and
there was like ground radar type comp
you know confirmation
similar to the one that happened with
the ship you know i mean the flying tic
tac ufo and everything
which i believe that pilot that saw that
and he had a lot of confirmation
from other people and there was video
footage of it you know from his [ __ ]
camera pod and stuff
so it is strange aircraft
and you know like i told you guys
my granddad was in isfahan
working for uh grumman aerospace
and uh i think you see the grommeter
arrow at that time i think it was
growing
and um they were executing a contract
on the f4 on the uh f-14 tomcat for
um the shah of iran so my granddad
and almost all of my aunts actually grew
up in isfahan
iran or liv they lived there for a long
time my aunts grew up there
my granddad actually he's half syrian
you know which i think i've mentioned
that before yeah he might have
yeah which is you know i guess it's kind
of funny you know
that you know i guess you never make me
[ __ ] well one-eighth
middle eastern yeah what is that
one-eighth yeah i guess it would be
yeah thank you zach thanks
but my understanding was
that his mom was a syrian christian
yeah might have had some do there's some
genocides and stuff that was going on
over there
around that time regrettably i do not
know
the history of the area
and uh anyway while they were there they
had that
iran ufo sighting i talked about it on
one of the other shows here
now my granddad didn't see it but he
knew about
the the occurrence he had heard about it
yeah and um
one of the intelligence communities came
to grumman and showed them
satellite data of one of the spy
satellites that picked up
an object in that area of where that
reported happened and moving away at
like
mach 10 plus they wanted to know if they
were
working on any kind of secret aircraft
yeah with a high mock
ability and they were like no because
that would have been illegal they were
they
i guess they were suspect that maybe
grumman was secretly
developing something for the show
without telling the us government
which you know that's a reasonable
assumption yeah you know
but um my granddad was uh evidently
convinced of it i didn't hear it
directly from him but i heard
heard about that through lois yeah you
know but he was my granddad was
convinced
that um the rally in air force had seen
an actual
extraterrestrial craft of some sort it
wasn't man-made
yeah no not with that performance
capabilities and not with what it did
he was convinced that's odd you know
and uh my granddad worked was contracted
for a lot of those big country
companies including he was on the saturn
project
uh with the with saturn v rocket and
also worked for
general atomics on that down what was
that thing that project uh
the nuclear spacecraft what was that
thing called oh [ __ ] man project um
uh i don't know
it had this uh craft that you could
launch it from the earth it was like a
20 it's about the size of a 20 or 30
story building
it was just solid steel it was like a
couple of down
submarines that's how much it weighed
and it would throw nuclear pellets off
the back of it little handheld
little like kind of like a half a damn
campbell soup can
little atomic bombs that throw them out
the back like three or four of them a
second and it [ __ ] rise up
out of the atmosphere and it could it
could get to mars in just a few weeks
and
get to jupiter in a couple months it was
like what was that thing called
project orion i think it was is that
right
orion i don't know all i know right yeah
that
[Laughter]
but they're talking about that there's
some more stuff they want to talk about
or do they want to show but i don't have
the details
maybe maybe maybe they released it the
last i'd heard it hadn't been released
yet yeah somebody said it wasn't getting
released till june first i'm not sure if
that's accurate or not
but i guess that's kind of the
scuttlebutt that's going around that
they're going to release like new [ __ ]
about it
right i don't know we'll see well and
till asked if anybody in the um
comments had ever seen a ufo tom keeps
wanting to see one
yeah never have seen one i've seen a
poltergeist he keeps leaving the death
experience i've been leaving the [ __ ]
open sorry
he's in the bedroom i'm telling all my
[ __ ] secrets
that's my secret to this yeah no i was
gonna say
um we don't have any secrets but um yeah
we have like a sliding glass door
like in the bedroom out to the patio and
you can see kind of the backyard and the
fence and stuff
and he leaves the curtains open at night
so he can look out there like always
played embedded hopefully
yeah yeah you caught him at project
orion you're right
it was project arrived my granddad was
on that
no okay yeah yeah we still haven't seen
one yeah i didn't know
though because that's that project that
project had been
classified for a long long long [ __ ]
time
i didn't know about that until he was
long retired and an old man
heard that through like aunts and uncles
that he was on that
and most of what he believed i heard
from aunts and uncles i didn't really
know
him all that much i met him a few times
i didn't really like the guy yeah
religious nut which it's a strange
restrained situation all those defense
contractors from that era
they didn't like to recruit people from
big universities they like to recruit
real talented people from the smaller
religious colleges
because they wouldn't rat they wouldn't
rat they'd keep
they were patriotic and they would keep
their [ __ ] mouth shut you couldn't
trust people from
ivy league schools they were two commies
they're two
they were too communist and if you gave
them a secret they'd sell it to the
soviets
so they they got them from christian
schools
true all right believe
no comment no i believe that they
thought that i didn't
i just don't know how [ __ ] would have
gone down nuclear
hey i'm just telling you the truth all
right because
nuclear secrets kept appearing in the
soviet union
and they came from people that worked on
the damn nuclear projects
and then they'd find out later that they
were part of communist groups that come
out of
universities and they were working in
physics and that they were
selling these secrets to the soviets so
anything that was secret
they tried to keep that away from
anything
from anybody who it was any anybody who
could have been in
any kind of communist party when they
were a kid
that's just telling you the truth that's
how it was
those intelligence agencies did not play
back then
back in the 50s and 60s [ __ ] no yeah i
know okay
jenny uh saunders says jenny has maybe
seen one i saw
i saw something but i don't think it was
an extraterrestrial spacecraft
when i first saw it i might have told
this story before
but i was driving home i used to work at
night and uh in daytona beach
and i was driving back to work from
my lunch hour because i guess i'd gone
home for lunch because i didn't live
that far away
so it was like maybe nine o'clock at
night and i saw something up in the sky
that i thought i didn't think it was a
ufo though i
thought that it was uh the planet killer
asteroid that's what it looked like it
looked like a big
fireball coming straight out of yeah
yeah and it looked like it was coming
like right at the and i was like
oh [ __ ] that's the extinction event
right there like i was wigging out and i
was just like i
i rushed back to work and i'm like you
guys you guys like [ __ ] asteroids get
the [ __ ] planet we're all dead or
whatever and then like i looked on the
internet and it was like
nothing nothing happened i don't know
what the [ __ ] it was oh i mean
the first thing i thought of well
actually the first thing i thought it
was a plane it exploded that was first
thing i thought of and then when i was
like looking at it because i saw it for
quite a while
and i was like no man i think that's a
[ __ ] asteroid
you know or like a meteor um and i was
like and that's really big
so i still don't know what it was nobody
else ever
seemed to see it nobody else said
anything about seeing anything weird in
the sky or like anything exploding or
anything like that
so i'm not real prone to hallucinations
so
i don't know what the [ __ ] that was that
i thought but
i never saw anything like that yeah
nothing
um i i've seen enough weird [ __ ] for my
lifetime in my lifetime you know
the weird paranormal stuff that i saw
out about experiences and
near-death experiences and poltergeists
and
precognition and dreaming true and
stuff like that but i always wanted to
see a ufo
a real one you know not a fake one you
know some of that shit's [ __ ]
but some of those some of the accounts
just couldn't have been fake there were
too many damn weirdnesses
like the phoenix lights incident that
happened
but there was also some disinformation
campaigns to cloud it
you know what i mean like the air force
went up and dropped flares
and then came back and said no you just
saw flares
i did see a video of some flares yeah
all right but that wasn't what people
were saying that's not what people were
describing
yeah all right there's a bunch of
there's a
bunch of way to put out disinformation
and to cloud a damn
topic so you don't have to talk about it
or just put some confusion in the topic
to make something deniable it's funny
you know after something's happened
you can use mind control to get people
to believe they saw something that they
didn't see
or that you can get other people who
didn't see it not to believe in it even
though it was something that really
happened
you can't trust any witness testimony
well memories
are [ __ ] fallible yeah if you suggest
like one thing enough times people will
start to believe
it's not everybody obviously but some
people will start yeah depends on
willpower
um and all that [ __ ] goes back to like
mk ultra when the cia was trying to
figure out how to do mind control
and they they researched all that [ __ ]
they know how to
[ __ ] with your mind and [ __ ] with public
opinion and
when that when george bush too
made that um that what was that
they made propagandizing the american
public legal
inside that patriot act and they and the
big
news networks have been doing that ever
since that day and it's
every year it's just worse and worse and
worse and that's why you know a lot of
people just don't believe that it's
unwatchable
you can just propagandize some
propagandize and
eventually it kind of gives uh
diminishing returns
i mean the soviets were doing it for so
long you know
eventually the average soviet citizens
and didn't even read their
uh their their their newspaper only like
real hardcore
believers in the system did but [ __ ]
what was the name of that
news pravda yeah pravda [ __ ] had it
just
towards the end of the soviet union just
had like a [ __ ] reputation it was just
mouthpiece for the [ __ ] uh
the ccp you know or not ccp that's
chinese the
mouthpiece for the ussr for russian
communist
party you know it just would say just
blatant untruths
and even even the soviet citizens knew
it was just not true
you know north korea doing the same
thing they tell the north koreans that
they live in the richest country
in the world no man they're like
the poorest country in the world i think
there's only like one country that's
even poorer than it
you know and
so you know
you can get you can only stretch people
and you can only twist people's minds
for so long before they
they realize they're being gas lit yeah
and then after a while they're just like
what yeah
whatever not listening right that's what
the union is reaching the end of its
cycle it's just part of history and
nature
it'll be all right fourth drawer down
says i've seen space junk burning up in
the atmosphere and that was mildly
alarming
maybe that's what i saw i mean it was
for sure like a big fireball
like big enough that it was like holy
[ __ ] if that's an asteroid and hits the
earth we're [ __ ]
there's a famous film of a uh meteor
going through the atmosphere parallel to
the horizon
through the desert somebody filmed it
thank you remember that back in the 70s
yeah thanks go ahead and read this thing
says when it comes to world-ending stuff
the idea of yellowstone erupting in the
fallout
such an upsetting idea to me and that's
actually not that's not that crazy
because
yeah you know there's all these you know
what i mean they make a lot of money and
those
you can really raise a lot of money
through fundraising through all these
little [ __ ] [ __ ] what's up
[ __ ] disasters that could happen you
know
remember there was acid rain and all
this other crap and now all this weird
[ __ ] global climate change and [ __ ]
none of that none of that's [ __ ]
all that [ __ ] would pale in comparison
to [ __ ]
something far more likely which would be
yellowstone erupting
massive [ __ ] underwater volcanoes or
meteor strikes there's just all kinds of
[ __ ] that's just
it's it's happened in the past they had
i think it was what was it in the 1800s
one of those
damn [ __ ] islands blew up
remember that they had like three or
four really hard winters
and and i think the daytime was orange
for like four or five days in a row
that was like in the 1860s i think yeah
and here in the united states nobody
knew what happened didn't even know what
it was
it was some volcanic eruption that
happened somewhere
well you know um that might have been
was that in 1816
sounds about right because that was the
year without a summer yeah
because there was like a really bad like
volcano and that was kind of like that
that's tied in with the whole mary
shelley and the geneva kind of thing
that's why the weather was like
four years it was cool yeah it was like
a long time well because like i said
when
a big volcano erupts like all of the ash
and [ __ ] like that
goes up into the atmosphere and like
essentially blocks the sun out yeah it
was like orange for four or five days
they didn't know what the hell happened
well yeah you wouldn't but they didn't
know that
yeah everybody everybody in the world
thought it was a damn local event
yeah it was something to happen way out
somewhere i don't know where was it uh
somewhere
exactly i don't even remember when it
said man i can't remember what
it was uh near greece or something god
damn it what the [ __ ] volcano was it
at it i've looked it up like enough
times because like i said it's it was
one of those things why
1816 why they call it a year without a
summer um
and like i said that was one of the
reasons thank you aaron
happy wednesday missed a few live shows
pouring wine
soon yeah get on in there where's i'm
already having somebody's
iceland i don't have it i don't think it
was iceland well no i can't make it with
somewhere near
indonesia wouldn't it well that's the
thing though i don't know
maybe we're not talking about the same
event i'm talking about the one that
happened
that made the weather suck yeah um
for like four years yeah five years it
was like a few years
yeah and then there were there for one
year there wasn't even a summer
it stayed winter yeah yeah
it didn't it wasn't like it depended on
what part of the world it wasn't like
freezing cold in some parts of the world
but it just never got
warm and so they didn't really have a
growing season that year
yeah and the weather was all [ __ ] up
because like i said that was the reason
that that volcano
indirectly was the reason that we have
the novel frankenstein
because mary shelley percy shelley lord
byron all them
they were stuck inside the house because
the weather was so [ __ ]
they couldn't go outside because it was
like pouring down rain it was like a
torrential rains for like days and days
at a time so they were stuck inside the
house and they were just like well [ __ ]
it we're just gonna write ghost stories
so that's what they did yeah
i still want to do a show about that
like i said i did a whole [ __ ] board
game about it over there
there's all kinds of weird events that
happened that had that damn tangus event
out in russia where it blew all the
trees down nobody knew it was
yeah the tunguska yeah
nobody knew what that was for a long
long time there was a nuclear explosion
happened out there
and that was before the atomic bomb that
was even i think that was right after
world war one wasn't it
or before world war ii yeah i want to
say it was like early nights like night
early 1919 or night yeah something like
that
right i think remember after the
communist revolution i think
or during the first part of it but um
they know what that was until a lot
later and it was just a
[ __ ] meteor came down
and it reached critical mass you know i
had and it exploded
like a nuclear bomb but it was above the
surface of the earth it exploded in the
air
yeah some people saw it they didn't know
what it was
blew it blew trees down for [ __ ]
miles yeah it's weird
there's pictures of it yeah yeah tila
said wasn't there a movie about the
creation of shelley's frankenstein yeah
there was one called gothic which ken
russell directed
uh which is on tubey actually if you
want to watch it and uh there was one
called haunted summer that had julian
sands
uh and actually there's a new one that
they added on shutter called a nightmare
wakes
that i think is about i haven't watched
it yet it doesn't have very good reviews
because like a lot of people are like
so boring but you know that doesn't mean
it's not good but i'll get around to
watching it one of these days
saxon is tambora and indonesia just like
i said in an education yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah maybe yeah
that's probably
it's like a it's like a volcano that
blew yeah
yeah gothic is a really really good
movie i keep put i keep putting it in
the poll like to do the review of it
because like i said i'm pretty sure it's
still on tubie
that you can watch it um i can't say who
the [ __ ] in it
[ __ ] read what maria said where is that
oh in the field in the army at fort
hood on 2am guard duty small meteorite
swept past me into the ground
yeah i didn't investigate because we
were on light discipline later uh heard
of longhorn scared before
that's weird meteorite went right past
you hit the ground
they had one uh out somewhere i think i
might have been in um
might have been in alabama where
somebody was
sitting in their front living room
watching television
and the meteor came down and hit the hit
the couch right next to him
i remember that it came right through
their roof yeah blue
blue blew everything up all the wraps
out you know [ __ ] vaporize can you
could imagine vaporized [ __ ] they they
all lived but there were [ __ ] wood
splitters everywhere
and you can't imagine we were just like
sitting here right now in a [ __ ]
media right now
yeah i would [ __ ] my pants i'm like yeah
there's all the fat old fat lady
old [ __ ] fat white lady sitting there
in the [ __ ] meteor
center yeah
late 60s see that's that's kind of like
an argument right there for always kind
of like
looking nice don't be just like laying
around your mum or whatever because you
never know when a meteor is going to hit
the house yeah the news crews are going
to show up
yeah and you're sitting there in your
muumuu with a big old [ __ ]
bucket of cheetos in your lap or some
[ __ ] like that that's with
my [ __ ] luck that's what happened
back when moomoos were sexy
were they i guess i guess [ __ ] wore
them
they didn't [ __ ] because they're
comfortable cause they don't wear them
they don't wear them because they're
sexy i don't know what they were
thinking i got you
i got you this thing you know i got news
for you when
when dudes aren't around women women
just like wear comfortable [ __ ] because
like a lot of the stuff that's like sexy
is not comfortable
no so it's like you don't if nobody's
gonna see you yeah [ __ ] man
if you're just gonna be around by
yourself and [ __ ] like that you're just
gonna like
lay around and like [ __ ] sweatpants
and t says wear clean underwear not
shave your legs or nothing like that
why would you you know i mean he says
wear clean underwear
right see you should always wear a clean
underwear for that exact very reason
yeah you never know i bet he walks
around t walks around a big old [ __ ]
stiletto platform
studded [ __ ] pumps
[Laughter]
tight pants she dressed up like [ __ ]
colored hair and stuff you know what i
mean purple hair she looked like
uh what's her name nicki minaj
that's all nicki minaj outfit well
phoebe she kind of had a little bit of a
new wave kind of look
oh i like nicki minaj she was cute you
got bad though
yeah it's kind of yeah tila says new
dude around take off that dang bra
right yeah yeah that underwire yeah yeah
well yeah it's like poking you in the
tit all the time
ginny got internal bra though she
doesn't really need bras
yeah i do though because i hate to say
but when you have big boobs yeah you
know they get all [ __ ] sweaty under
there
that's true i guess it's like pretty
they're always like flopping
yeah yeah i mean like even when i go out
to walk you have to have like that the
t says i gotta eat yeah one thing i will
never understand
is that i always liked uh
you know i kind of like the look of
those like really long like fake nails
and [ __ ]
but the few times that i've actually
like bought them and worn them out
the first time i go to the bathroom they
all fall in the toilet she had a problem
with them
well because it's like you have you have
to go like that like to get your pants
down so you go to the bathroom and then
like they just go dork
you got it and then they fall in the
toilet yeah you need to hang out with
black girls so after that i was just
kind of like yeah but well
i mean the thing about it is that why
like why make everything harder for
yourself
likewise i can't even i can't touch my
phone i can't
ghetto fabulous i can't like pull my
yeah pull my pants
up i can't you know it's like why the
[ __ ] would i want to just make
everything difficult for myself
like everything funny i haven't i'm
klutzy enough as it is
yeah it's true it's see i'm clutzy
enough as it is i don't need to like
give myself for their hand
she she dolls up pretty good though
i clean up she dolls up pretty good when
they're in their goth outfits and stuff
it's just
it you gotta kind of have to balance out
the [ __ ]
tomboy with the sex bomb attributes of
[ __ ] shiny because jenny's actually a
tomboy
she's a tomboy but she has sex bomb at
attributes
you know i like to think that i'm a nice
balance of both things
you're more reasonable than the average
sex bomb
see that's right i have that but i don't
have like all the downsides where i'm
not i'm not real high maintenance
yeah high maintenance high hormonal
imbalances of either too much estrogen
too much testosterone difficult to deal
with
no there's no reason or logic there it's
just all i mean give me give me give me
i want i want i want you see i'm not at
all
one of those i'm pretty chill yeah you
know what i mean yeah
i have a you know like a man do you like
dealing with a man
[Laughter]
he hates that [ __ ] though but
she thinks she's a feminist but i'm like
no you're not famous it's more like
you're just kind of like a dude
am i like a dude yeah in certain ways
you are in certain ways you are i am
kind of like
not normal not in the disgusting like
i'm scratching my balls
you're real reasonable real reasonable
which that's very
uncommon in women well the thing about
it is that
actually that's actually why we stayed
together was that you were reasonable
the thing about it though is sometimes
certain types of
women because i've been friends with a
lot of women throughout my life i have
found that
90 of women at least 90 of women that
i've been friends with are completely
and utterly reasonable
however um i think sometimes they act up
in certain ways to get stuff out of
dudes so that's not
exactly like what they're really like
when they're not around dudes
like when they're around other chicks
they're you know
they're they're just normal but i think
sometimes they're putting [ __ ] on
you know what i'm saying yeah i just
don't do that because
i'm just not i'm not real good at being
like fake you know what i mean i'm not
really good at like pretending to be
something i'm not
you know what i mean which like i said
that's why
that's why this show is like it did this
is this is us like unfiltered we're just
yeah this is exactly what we're like
whether the camera's on i got to talking
about her nails
talking about how hard those acrylics
are see
yeah i'm gonna get her talking about her
hair next
that black woman talking about her hair
that [ __ ] go on [ __ ] there she's like
which hair are you talking about that
hair this hair that
although you know what i mean today i
was thinking about telling you that you
needed wigs so
because it'd be better for me because
it's like a different woman in bed every
time well yeah
see that's yeah get that wig and those
shoes come over here
see man i got to do so much work like to
get you know what i mean
but i didn't want to go to the gym
though yeah
i'm trying to sit around healing up well
yeah that's what i mean you don't go to
you go to the gym maybe once a week
or twice twice a week twice because the
rest of the time is just oh god although
i tell you what
do you [ __ ] dudes out there know what
i know now i would have went on trt at
[ __ ] 40.
i would have went on at 40. after i saw
my blood work at 51 oh this is [ __ ] i
should have been on this [ __ ]
10 years ago and then like just what a
difference it makes just in recovery and
mental
[ __ ] acuity and uh just feels so much
more positive you don't feel that
[ __ ] damn hand to death
and uh yeah if you if you were getting a
little unreasonable yeah i was getting
like i ain't gonna make it
yeah and it was just like the past maybe
four months five months but it was
slowly getting worse
you know what i mean i just i don't it's
not like suicidal that felt like
something was coming to get me yeah
that's what you kept saying
and i kept trying to tell you i'm like
look nothing's coming to get like what
do you think's going to get you like
bigfoot what are you wearing
i felt like it was like a big lion or
something or the or the grim reaper or
something or that thought
fate was coming to get me that thing
thank you zach man you just keep like
checking
out like i'm full of damn money [ __ ] i'm
gonna start taking off clothes here in a
bit
zach really no
i was like wow it's so early trying to
get him give me more money zach says in
high school there was a black girl fight
and i didn't see it but apparently after
it was over there's just a pile of weave
left behind yeah yeah yeah
that's the weak spot they start pulling
right [ __ ] leaves
yeah yeah well you know you can't blame
you gotta go after the vulnerability
you know well that shit's not cheap man
that's just seen that i've seen videos
of it yeah yeah
the [ __ ] goes down on a saturday night
at the gas station when they're [ __ ]
coming there to gas up
and the [ __ ] dudes are [ __ ]
talking [ __ ] then the women start
talking [ __ ] then the women start
fighting each other then the dudes start
trying to break then the girls take off
their earrings yeah and then you know
applied and the [ __ ] titties go
flopping out there
this is back when they had the little
[ __ ] tube tops you know what i mean
and they were gone
and if you're gonna fight black girls
and i got
pictures to [ __ ] prove it okay all
right black girls
your nudity is high on her list
he's in there [ __ ] laughing she knows
it's true but
the advantage is not so much to beat the
other girl's ass
is to take her weave off and to get her
clothes off
i saw it and then take a picture start
pulling yes
[Laughter]
humiliation exactly
so you end up with your [ __ ] little
tube skirt pulled up around your [ __ ]
midriff
gucci hanging out and you put the shoes
flying [ __ ]
your [ __ ] tube top up around your
neck your weave gone and you're rolling
around on the ground
out in front of the gas pumps with a
[ __ ] whole bunch of dudes laughing
well yeah with a couple dudes trying to
separate them and then the other guys
on the video dudes trying to stop it
we're being stuck by other dudes trying
to prevent it from being stuck
no no yeah they got the thumbs up let it
play out
[Laughter]
i believe it yeah world star hip hop
they'll [ __ ] put that [ __ ] on there
but yeah i was just thinking today even
though i just literally like a couple
weeks ago like bought a bulk thing and
black hair dye
today i was thinking myself maybe i
should go get some bleach and some red
because i was in walgreens the other day
getting some
like some medicine or something and uh
i saw the red hair dye and i was just
kind of like man i know i've been
talking about going back to red maybe i
should do that
but i have to bleach this like i think
last time i did it i had to bleach it
like three times maybe four times before
it was like
light enough to get the red to stay on
yeah and the only thing i didn't like
about that red is that man it just got
gets all over the place
stains all the pillowcases
yeah it's almost just maybe i should buy
some red pillowcases or you know just
buy a [ __ ] really good
red wig i yeah i have been thinking
about doing that too because i was just
kind of like maybe i should just get
instead of eggs or extensions we'll just
get some wigs
yeah because then it's a lot easier
remember how hard that was and you had
to re we i had to help you do that [ __ ]
every two or three weeks okay no i did
it every week
every week yesterday because because the
red will fade
because i don't want [ __ ] pink ass
hair you know what i mean it looks like
[ __ ] quick
yeah i wanted it to be like bright
vibrant red so if you wanted to be
bright vibrant red you pretty much
what i would do was that i would only
wash it like two or three times a week
and also like
when i was in between washes i would
comb dye through it
and then kind of just rinse it and
condition it you know what i mean
so there would always be red dye in
there so it would stay
and you had and you had the sides and
the back your head shaved i was
constantly shaving back in those days
and it was still a lot to keep up with
it was yeah
i have a lot of hair yeah she constantly
sheds hair
and i just cut it shorter i mean just
for that very reasonably a lot of hair
one day i woke up because it was almost
down in my butt at this point and i was
just kind of like man i'm so [ __ ]
sick of this hair it's like it weighs a
ton
and it's just always you every time i
wash it like big
clumps fall out every time i brush it
all the clumps fall out
and i'm just kind of like and it's
always been like that it just seems like
i never have
thinner hair you know what i mean
there's just so much of it it's like
never
ending so the other day i just cut it to
my shoulders
because i was like sick of dealing with
it and it was like heavy
but you know even then it's like i still
just like have big chunks of [ __ ]
hair like every time i run my hand
through my hair like
i have hair on my fingers t
and dj maniac are [ __ ] talking about
i think they're talking about how much
actual weave you find laying around on
the ground in the hood
i don't know what it is until you come
right up on it you get that and look at
oh okay
like what is that is that a dead animal
yeah
yeah that'd be fine zach says i wish i
was a natural redhead man
um yeah it's it's sad because it's like
a lot of people
i left my hair in my natural red color
for a really long time
um but then it was just easy i don't
know because i think i had started dying
it black like after i met you right so i
don't even think you've ever seen me
with my natural hair color other than
like pictures
yeah um i don't know i just i left it
like that for a long time and i was like
[ __ ] it i'm just gonna start dyeing it
black because i thought that when i got
older like it would just start going
gray and it wouldn't be pretty anymore
so it didn't ever happen though well i
don't know it might be grey now i don't
think so
i'd see it in the roots i don't think it
is
i have like little i have little gray
hairs like sometimes like right here
like by my ears but i don't know it
doesn't seem too gray up here she's kind
of reddish
but i don't know i've been coloring it
so long
he says it reminds her of the fake booty
on the desk for the club years ago that
i don't really know exactly
maybe there's some kind of a booty
like what they used to call those things
that they had they had fake booty in the
1800s
it's called a bustle yeah remember that
yes that was just kind of something that
i had a halloween
butt and then you had it you had your
skirt would go over the bottom or
you could also do what i had like i had
a halloween costume it's like a
victorian kind of looking thing
and that had a bustle but it was like
outside so you kind of like strapped it
here but it was like it had like a
frame like underneath it yeah i think
all but so it like stuck out
yeah made it look like you had a like
had a big old butt a big
well i i think i i don't think the big
butt is what they were going for we
didn't think what they were going for
was the optical illusion of an even
smaller weight
yeah everything was like well it was
just kind of like in the 80s with those
big [ __ ] shoulder pads
right everything was in service of
making your waist look smaller
right because like that was like the
that was like the main thing of whether
or not you were a hottie in the 1800s is
what
is if you had a tiny corseted waist
and they would corset the waist down to
where sometimes it would actually kill
those women
they died yeah [ __ ] because it's
rearranging i mean
your kinds of internal organs your
organs only have so much
to move around i think they were totally
i don't think they were totally aware of
how big eternal organs were and what
they were supposed to do anyway
they were like yeah just and you know um
my friend melissa she was corseted she
did it to herself she was real good at
putting on her own corsets and
everything
and would have other people put on she
just wear them for [ __ ] days on end
and she said that it happens naturally
that without you even thinking about it
it slowly gets
loot it feels like it's getting looser
but what it is is that you're actually
getting smaller you're conforming to it
and she said it happened quick like
within six or seven months she had
and she was about your height and
probably about your weight
wait and she had a waist that was you
know that big around
[ __ ] yeah and she said she actually had
to
stop tightening it you know what i mean
yeah to put it on loose because she was
getting too dangerously small
i think at one point when i was still
um you know when i was still doing the
corsets a lot
i think i got down to an 18-inch one
yeah eventually yeah i think that that's
what happened i think the one i have in
there was
24 maybe yeah 26. i can't remember
you would just come up a real skinny
phase though during that time
yeah i got down like i got down really
yeah she got down real
small she's you're getting back down
there again but you were even
lighter then yeah you were so light that
i was saying you need to gain some
weight
remember that yeah everybody was telling
me yeah
i didn't have anorexia or anything like
that but i i got down to a point where
um i start i was having heart
palpitations and i had to go to a
cardiologist
yeah because i'd been heavy and then i
lost
like 90 pounds or something like that in
five months
and what the [ __ ] and my heart did not
know what to do it was like
i was like passing out all the time
what's his name had the same thing
happen to him that dude who had that
bypass
ash yeah yeah he lost what 300 pounds
yeah a lot yeah he had a gastric he lost
like 300 pounds
yeah and he was like dude man i think
i'm going to die
my heart is yes yeah i had the same
thing yeah and i said jenny had that
same thing you didn't lose 300 you lost
no it was like it was 90. all right and
it was actually a little too much you
really
probably should have only lost about 60.
yeah
you know well i was just so happy
because i'm like wow i'm skinny i've
never been skinny my whole entire life
you said once it started it was just
easy it was just falling off
yeah once i got into um once i got into
a habit
of not eating all that much like i
wasn't starving
but i was like i was probably eating
under a thousand calories a day
um and she you guys once i got down
like once i got used to after a couple
weeks like not eating all that much it
was like super easy and everything just
like fell right i think you got down to
what 125
118. 118. that was how low
i'm i think i look best right around 135
yeah more than normal i look like a
normal size like when i was down to 118
likes people started asking me if i was
like sick
are you sick yeah
so yeah that wasn't like i was excited
because i was just saying i'm recording
people didn't recognize it they didn't
yeah because it didn't take very long
they didn't lose it they were like who's
that new girl and this is that that's
not a new girl
yeah it's just and that's it that's not
stable who is that
and i have to describe who that was yeah
because
90 pounds made a huge difference it
really did yeah we're on recording
that's completely different
and there we go that's her and i said
yeah that's her yeah yeah
it was crazy yeah it was a trip she lost
at 90 pounds and
and her skin your skin held together and
everything you know you couldn't tell
that you had been real heavy
yeah i don't think you could get away
with that now
you lose that much weight it's hard to
set it's hard to tell who knows
what skin does it at our age yeah you
were younger then
not much younger i think that we've been
that much younger was it well i think it
was 10 years ago 10 years ago yeah
nine years ago something like that that
i lost all that weight because i mean
i've been
i was skinny when i was a little kid but
as soon as i went through puberty
my body was like hey time for you to get
fat now
yeah so you know so i kind of chubbed
out like after i was
about 12 or whatever and then i lost a
bunch of weight in my 20s
um because i started playing soccer and
[ __ ] like that
but so 6 inches back up and then when i
moved in with him i think i gained like
30 pounds because of his cooking
soaps in the club soap's in the car
she's just
uh leaving the gym oh okay yeah
see what beeznes says her boobs make up
80 percent of her weight they probably
do at this point yeah
they're they're you got some great boobs
they're very happy [ __ ] could be
[ __ ] mesmerizing
he's like look at him moving back and
forth he's so funny especially
especially now that you're like back out
the testosterone or whatever
like i'll just be i'll be sitting there
and we'll be watching a movie or
something like that and then i see him
like looking at him you know
like looking over like yeah i'm like
what are you looking at
me it's like you know like be like me
sitting here is like a dumb ass thinking
it's like do i have a bugger fight
hanging out in my nose
like that what are you looking at tina's
sister i think there's something wrong
tina says somebody's fake butt fell off
on the dance floor and everyone laughed
and danced around it
no one touched it well i would hope not
who the hell is going to touch someone
else's fake ass
i'm certainly not going to that's
[ __ ] funny can you imagine how
embarrassing
that would be if you had a fake butt and
it fell out and everyone
and everyone saw that [ __ ] yeah you
would never you could never go back to
that club ever again
you'd have to go in disguise i would
depends on how much
as much of a sense of humor yeah i mean
you would have to literally like play it
off you know what i mean
yeah because i mean
fake i've i've like tripped and fallen
at eyebar a couple times and a couple
like a few times i've done it where i
wasn't even drunk i was just like
because i'm just real classy like i
remember i fell down the stairs
from the dj booth yeah and i was sober
why i just got there
but it's just like i said i'm just a
spaz and i can't walk apparently
um so i fell down the [ __ ] stairs
luckily it was like pretty early in the
night so some people saw me but like not
that betty that i was just kind of like
ta-da
i guess now for my next trick
according to um this is i guess around
2010
2012 they had a damn
little documentary or somehow something
on the news that said
some girls here in florida got in
trouble for
doing booty injections on girl's hair
and and evidently there was like an
epidemic
of florida stripper girls they were all
black girls
getting the damn fake booty injections
and there was a brazilian girl that was
doing it for him
and she was putting [ __ ] in there man
that just doesn't belong in a goddamn
doing the fix of like doing basically
tire repair kits that was one yeah going
to [ __ ] home depot
[ __ ] and then like injected into
people's asses yeah it sounds [ __ ]
crazy it made more sense once i
looked into it to see what it was they
were talking about
they had like a silicone repair kit
for tires and a gigantic [ __ ] needle
on it i mean the [ __ ] needle was like
an eighth of an inch in diameter
with like a slick cut on it and they
would stick that some girl's ass
and it's a huge [ __ ]
big round bubble of
[ __ ] silicone that would dry
into a hard
round bubble would be flat up against
the bottom of it but but it would be
like you know what i mean
and it kind of made a solid implant
inside of a girl's ass
and that's what he and and then they
were had to sit on the [ __ ]
imagine sitting on that thing like yeah
you'd have to like take one of those
hemorrhoid pillows everywhere you went
look at the hole in the middle
but anyway it's it's
it there's some industrial solvents
involved in this [ __ ] and it's
coming out of a container that isn't it
isn't sterile
yeah and there's a chance of [ __ ]
infection and stuff and it's not that
was one of the things that they were
doing another one is they were just
taking industrial silicone
and they were heating it up to try to
kill bacteria in there because you don't
know what it's been stored in
and then they would just put it into a
damn hypodermic syringe and just inject
it with needles
you know what i mean small and they
would just keep doing lots and lots of
injections all
around there and you could get a
good-looking booty
if you like size you could do it and if
you had
artistic skill you know you could get it
shaped pretty good
the problem was is the you could they
said that
what they were injecting in there you
know what i mean it wasn't real
consistent
for all you know there might have been
some impurities in certain batches of it
to cause irritation
or infection and in that same program
they were showing them taking it out
they would just take a dab
needle a hypodermic needle and without
the syringe on it
and stick it all over the ass like pin
cushions and then just rub
like that and try to get it to go out
that needle
they were trying to drain it all out
that way
and what was funny is that she's
spending [ __ ]
thousands of dollars to get some doctor
some to get the damn silicone juice out
of her booty
for like a thousand dollars a couple
thousand dollars to eat per
treatment and i'm going like [ __ ]
should have seen me i could do that i'd
do that for a couple hundred bucks
i didn't take any damn skill you don't
need to do that
just rub on it big old glue booty and
just i'm getting no no no i'm just
getting it out of there
it's coming out see here's another
business that sean can
yeah you can get a little truck yeah do
booty fixing
got all these [ __ ] black strippers
lined up out the door for a [ __ ]
booty shrinkage sitting in there
my mask on my rubber gloves i get to
design your logo
yeah you can be back there with a
[ __ ] video camera and we'll make a
whole video series
make a special fetish video series oh my
god
called booty reversal
[Laughter]
i'm a [ __ ] genius [ __ ] marketing
genius
and we'll sell a whole [ __ ] like
finish line and they have videos
getting stylish with the drainage
tila says i don't even think you're
supposed to sit down for a month or so
after butt lifts or injections
there's no challenge how do you manage
that so you just have to like lay around
on your [ __ ]
stomach all the time that sucks she said
they read and sheba says they recommend
saline but the thing is is that saline
is absorbed by the body so it'd only be
temporary it's safe
yeah but it would um i don't think that
would last but maybe a couple days
oh i don't know yeah i mean there's some
weird [ __ ] that i've seen
and it's appeared in some weird ass
[ __ ] porn before i imagine [ __ ]
zach bryan knows all about this [ __ ]
this [ __ ] perverted [ __ ] ass you
take it down
okay you take
actually you know this is not a gay
thing you know you had straight dudes
that were doing this
okay but it's very evidently popular in
the gays in the gay world too
in the fetish the world of gay
[Laughter]
you take an iv bag full of saline with a
[ __ ]
needle on a regular iv bag that you'd
give for a person who's
conked out from um dehydration
you want the big big bag of it you take
that
and you stick that into a dude's nuts
and you just sit there and hop
and you just sit there and just let that
iv bag drip down into that dude's nuts
nuts to get like the size of a damn
cantaloupe all right
and it's kind of absorbed in there
and then it starts like within about an
hour
so it all goes to his [ __ ] rod
and that [ __ ] gets to be about five
inches in diameter and like about 18
inches long does it look like a big old
beer can
it looks bigger like bigger than a beer
and evidently it aches like [ __ ]
crazy but the dudes kind of get off on
it
and then they try to have sex with that
okay
good luck now i first heard about this
at man
i first heard about this at man race man
raise was that
golf club that had a fetish night in
boston
and and there were dudes at [ __ ] mit
and harvard and so
it had these harvard medical students
they were just [ __ ]
nerdy as [ __ ] showing up to them
fetish knight all right in the damn
g-string with their dick like that
okay that [ __ ] is [ __ ] gigantic you
know what i mean walking around
semi-nude or nude with this [ __ ] go and
check it
yeah yeah yeah yeah the girls taking
pictures and [ __ ] like that
[Laughter]
anyway i was up at the bar
and [ __ ] the dude was there [ __ ]
he had some girls with him and [ __ ]
and that's when i [ __ ] first met him
and says dude how the [ __ ] did you do
that he told me how he did that
and he was laughing and he said that he
and his buddies
that were all med students right would
scare the [ __ ] out of girls by doing
that on a date
and the girl didn't know and then he
they'd [ __ ] unveil that [ __ ]
and those girls would just be [ __ ]
like aghast
[Laughter]
they try to dudes are [ __ ] perverted
you know what i mean
even in harvard they're [ __ ] anything
yeah because you think most you think
most chicks would be like yeah no i'm
out
nah he said that they would just be but
he
he climbed out there and his buddies he
and his medical buddies
would like get a big charge out of the
[ __ ] reaction
you know i mean that the horror
it's nerd humor yeah i suppose
it's like hey look i have a big old
[ __ ] that's why i first heard about
that [ __ ]
that's really funny well yeah you're
lucky because that students knew about
it
yeah i mean the one big fetish party i
went to also at a place called man ray
but it was in fort lauderdale
yeah um all i remember from that one was
just like the tvs playing a bunch of
scat porn
oh [ __ ] that was kind of like
[Music]
not my thing i gotta say no judgment
but thomas says this conversation has me
dying
oh my god that's thorn not thomas
thorne cezanne oh thorn yeah yeah
almost like damien thorne like the
antichrist
big weenie of horror oh my god
well remember like we kind of went off
on a thing
um watching the that porn of like dudes
that like getting their nuts stepped on
by girls and stilettos yeah you know
what i mean maria says i'm your token
post menopausal fan
there's a thing called post post
menopausal red
distribution of fat and know all about
it and my age ain't got time to try to
fix it i'd rather have a flat ass
then lots of pain at my age uh yeah um
looked into that um small doses like
we're talking about 1 10
the dose for a male one tenth of those
testosterone for a female and clomid
that uh those which are pretty cheap can
actually the effects of test on
postmenopausal
females good because it aromatizes into
in into estrogen also which gives you a
a testosterone and estrogen base that
you need
having clomid can also kick start your
pituitary gland to produce
some of the other um glands to make them
[ __ ] produce like clomid makes me
prevents me from having heartburn
i don't really i can eat like a kid i
can eat anything now
and that's because of that clomid all my
other glands are produced
so the only trade-off is is that you
can't
post-menopausal women can't get that
[ __ ]
real fat laden
rounded [ __ ] cherub kind of look that
say like a pregnant teenager
look gets you're not gonna that's all
okay that's you're not gonna have that
estrogen look but you can
you can get a more athletic look um
as long as you're taking um
you know hormone injections testosterone
you'll get more athletic you'll burn a
lot of fat
you'll have better muscle definition you
can look at it you can see photographs
of what post-menopausal women
look like on tests it looks good but you
just don't want to go
into doses that take you into the realm
of male levels of testosterone it'll
cause your voice to change
and then the next thing after that would
be slight hair you know facial hair
so you want to keep it within female
range
uh but just like maybe at the higher end
higher ends of female range will
um really boost libido um
high testosterone levels still within
the female range
exogenous through the needle you could
turn a woman into a damn sex zombie
just they just want to have sex
sex zombie oh what's his name you know
what i mean
some of these damn serial killers weird
ass trying to turn make a sex zombie by
drilling the holes in the head no that's
not that's jeffrey
jeffrey no no just testosterone yeah sex
zombie
somebody sent me a thing today that said
they're making netflix is making like a
a series like about jeffrey dahmer not i
don't think it's a
i don't think it's a documentary series
i think it's like a fictionalized yeah i
have to say a disclaimer though i'm not
a doctor i'm not giving medical advice
yeah you better say that yeah yeah yeah
i'm not a doctor do your own research
from reputable people that's done it and
look at photographs
look at photographs and see what it is
you're talking about it's it's quite
impressive
quite impressive with people don't have
to age
the way that they uh that you think that
they do
well in the way that they used to but
like i said you know people aren't
eating like
uh you know blue steaks and three
martinis for longer yeah and they had no
idea
back in those days they had no idea how
the endocrine system worked
when your teeth fell out you replaced
your teeth you put false teeth back in
okay so you got teeth replacement when
your hormones fall out
you can put hormones back in it's called
hormone replacement
okay you can do that too it's highly
effective
highly effective and as long as you're
not a [ __ ] steroid user
or bumping [ __ ] super physiological
[ __ ]
levels of testosterone or hormones as
long as you haven't been doing that
since you were [ __ ] a teenager
it doesn't have a a a bad effect on your
body
all these dudes from the golden era you
know arnold and all these other guys who
died you know
and arnold's got a bad heart now they
were [ __ ] damn they were doing
big amounts of oral steroids
since they were kids of course they're
going to develop problems
but if you're already in your 50s or
your 40s you don't have enough time yet
for any of that to affect you if
anything that will expand your life
if anything it will extend it yeah i
think the problem arises when you've
just been doing it for so many
that's so long and then by the time
you're old there's no gas left in your
tank
yeah you've been taking that [ __ ] at
high dosages it's just run
for 40 50 years you're just running to
the ground
that's something you do in the second
half of your life at reasonable levels
as long as you know what you're doing
and you see good
and here's nothing you don't go to
doctors for this doctors don't know
because general practitioners are just
doing what they're told and they say
what they're what they're
an endocrinologist will know and um
muscle heads guys that come out of gyms
because they're doing human
experimentation on themselves
and other people they so they have human
trials right there
and a lot of those guys are some of
those guys are doctors that are doing it
and they're working out
so doctors take drugs that's another
thing that people doctors take drugs yes
doctors take drugs well i mean i thought
even in like the 80s i remember there
being like kind of an epidemic
yeah well i mean why wouldn't you be
because you can have access to it and
get all the good [ __ ] yeah
and they know and they and they kind of
know the potentials and they'll use them
on themselves
you know yeah see that's what i mean i
just really like i i only just realized
we have the same shirt on again
we have the same shirt on again [ __ ] god
damn it he usually comes in checks he
didn't check i forgot
[Laughter]
i might my drink is empty yeah okay
stuff he said talk to dom doctor tom
wants to inject himself soap you're
[ __ ] low t bro
he thinks everybody you're like she's
got the symptoms and she's
and she's a vegetarian that should make
it that she'll collapse your [ __ ]
and and just her lifestyle
i didn't stay but here's the thing
here's the thing so
i didn't say start [ __ ] banging it up
i said go get your blood work done
i suspect it go get your blood work done
go look at your free testosterone and
see how that [ __ ] compares
to what the normal range of females i
bet you you're just [ __ ]
in the dirt
oh my god i haven't had my blood test in
a long time
the only other problems i used to have
uh
i used to have high cholesterol and it's
not so much anymore um because i
kind of cut down on a lot of [ __ ] you
know
meat dairy that kind of stuff i do eat
some of it still but not as much as i
used to
so that kind of helps and um they keep
checking it because uh diabetes runs in
my family so i have to keep getting it
checked but since i haven't had
insurance since
2016 2015
something like that so i haven't had
blood work done in a really long time
but you know
so i don't know i feel okay so i'm just
keeping fingers crossed it's like well i
don't feel like [ __ ] so
maybe that means that nothing's wrong i
know but you know
what are you gonna do nothing i just i
was just talking to a friend the other
day
about i'm kind of one of those people
because i guess i grew up you know kind
of poor too so
you really kind of had to be [ __ ]
dying or you a
broken bone or something like that
before you would you know before they
would take it
but my parents would take the hospital
because they're like you did are you
sure i want to go to the hospital
because it's like it's gonna be really
expensive
so it's like they didn't take you just
for [ __ ] stuff most stuff you just
kind of had to figure out on your own
you know what i mean
but luckily i didn't luckily i didn't
break any bones when i was a kid
and i didn't really get real sick as a
kid either i still don't get real sick
we had that um you know we had that food
poisoning [ __ ] well it wasn't even food
poisoning but you know what i mean
that that gross [ __ ] we had the other
day
but other than that i don't really i
don't even get colds or
flu or anything like that i can't really
even remember the last time i got
anything like that at least anything
that was um bad enough for me to like
not get out of bed
you know i can't remember the last time
that happened i think the last time it
happened it was food poisoning again
sucks but i've never had cold or flu bad
enough to not
not get out of bed
four throw down said you were going to
be the world's first 150 year old man
um no
you want what are you doing pokey yeah
well hey
look at her she's gonna go outside yes
she did that
she tear off the side of the chair and
then running out yeah she's like come on
well she can't say come on so she has to
come up and be like
hey hey seriously though before we
started the show
it's like she wanted to go out on the
back porch so we opened the door she
goes in the back porch and then like
literally a second later she was like no
[ __ ] this i'm coming back in
she don't like it i guess it was like
too hot outside i think it's 80.
let me see what temperature it is
outside it
is 83 degrees oh my god it's a
degree hotter than it was when i checked
earlier
it's 83 degrees but it's um that's
fahrenheit
but it's uh it's cloudy outside it says
yeah
it is a little bit did she go out or no
she's not at the front
oh okay she wants to sit on the front
porch
or on the driveway by the car
yeah thorn says i hate going to doctors
especially getting older they always
find something wrong
i mean
that's the thing it's like everybody has
something that could be improved i guess
but
i just kind of figured like shit's not
broke don't fix it if i feel like crap
yeah then i'll go get something seen too
but if i don't feel like crap then i'm
not gonna worry about it
you know what i mean like you said they
might find some other [ __ ] that
then they're like hey i don't trust them
they need to take medication for this
and it's like then that'll make me feel
even more like crap so i'm just like oh
no thanks
i'm you know i'm in preventative
maintenance and stuff
that's just all i just like that well
like i said i'm just kind of like
i don't i i feel okay so i'm not
worrying about it
if i start feeling like [ __ ]
consistently then yeah i might all do
something about it but i don't feel like
[ __ ] consistently
only thing i am all the time is tired
but that's just because i don't sleep
very well
because i wake up all the time in the
middle of the night that's all
so there's like a reason for that
maria says it's 39 here and raining i
actually kind of wish i was talking to
zach earlier
on facebook and um he said he feels a
lot more creative and stuff when it's
warm or hot outside and i was like man
not me
as soon as it gets hot and now this is
like my least favorite time
of the year because i know that summer
is going to be here
soon and man the heat in florida just
[ __ ] wears you down
you know what i mean it's just after a
while
i mean we have air conditioning on all
the time and it's like i try to stay
inside most of the time except for
going out for walks in the morning i try
to go like really early in the morning
like at seven in the morning
before it gets too hot but even then
it's like the humidity is just
it's just it's draining so i always feel
a lot more
energetic when it's cold out it doesn't
and that's the thing it doesn't really
get cold in florida
all that much okay i dropped three links
in the in the chat
to um a girl what
what it looks like what a female looks
like
under the influence of under the
influence
yeah she's at female levels she's not at
male level
testosterone doses but female levels so
you guys can look
yeah she asked what is 83 fahrenheit in
real money as in what is it
what is it in celsius i don't know
actually
so megan needs to look that up 83
degrees fahrenheit what is that celsius
does it say on my phone
let's see let's see
no of course it doesn't you guys you
can't see the links that's
that's what i shared
well there you go
this is what she looks like in in
clothes
so you know they don't look manly
someone goes nah i like being around and
squishy yeah i kind of do too
[Laughter]
before throwing doubt goes gosh
brittany goes yes i want to start
getting back into heavyweights so i
could look like the discount version
of that chick dang she is goals
there's a lot of them up there
actually instagram kind of replaced the
action movies as far as the damn
fitness scene and it even replaced a lot
of the damn
bodybuilding shows instagram's got all
the [ __ ]
just [ __ ] exotic looking people like
what the [ __ ]
and then like some of them are almost
kind of like
some of these girls are taking
testosterone in the low end the male
range
they one of them that is bakar nabiba
i think she was she's some middle
eastern girl she lives here in florida
now
she moved and moved here with her
boyfriend
she's got kind of a guy's voice a male
sounding voice but it's kind of sexy she
looks great you know she looks this
freaky looking
goth chick um but
just she's got to be maybe only two
percent body fat and a whole lot of
muscle and it's all a
lower body muscle um
big black contact lenses and stuff
and ponytails and it's just you didn't
you you didn't see
people like that you know gr when i was
a kid growing up she looks like a bond
villain
you know what she looks like it looks
like a bond
like you know like like like a bond
villain sidekick
[Laughter]
i'll chill some pictures here hold on oh
my god i want to look like a bonding
yeah she's just like what the [ __ ] i
need an underground lair
yeah it's exactly to get on that that's
exactly what she looks like
an underground layer let me show you she
looks like a [ __ ] bond villain
yeah um
she was like wanting to be in the movies
see
should a good photograph of keep talking
jenny
well i'm just i was waiting for you and
then well you know because then i'm
going to start talking about something
and then you're just going to interrupt
because you're getting you know me
so i always got to wait
okay but it's just
it's almost kind of like transhumanism
well i mean if you have the means if you
don't want to look like a human if you
want to look like kind of like well then
[ __ ] man you do you i was no skin off my
ass
like i said i kind of like some freaky
looking some freaky looking
[ __ ] she looks like uh day amanda glass
a little bit
at least from that quick glance that's
off
yeah okay shouldn't look that weird i
thought i was expecting like
somebody like super weird looking well
here i've actually i'll keep going
she looks pretty normal except for the
except for the consciousness
the the proportions are not
yeah but like i said i was expecting
something much weirder
that's all lady lair
like a cooler version of a she shed
[ __ ] she [ __ ] i can't believe that
that's the female equivalent of man cave
i don't know who came up with that [ __ ]
this is what tom does all day he just
like just all day
looks a picture of chicks on instagram
she's probably shocked i actually look
at the dudes too
yeah i do kind of feel like i mean a lot
of it is filters and photoshop and [ __ ]
like that no i'm seeing i'm seeing
[ __ ] what dudes my age are looking
like
like the top notch too you know what i
mean looking i'm into it
see yeah that's a cool
uh cool cool outfit that's a cool dress
actually
i have a top a little bit like that but
that's not normal proportions
well obviously look at those thighs
and and at like maybe five percent body
fat three percent body fat no
that's just so that's not you know
that's enhanced
not within normal right you know that's
not normal
lady lair yeah
everybody says it isn't a barn so i
can't call it a [ __ ] barn
see i like [ __ ] barn better than she
should she shed just sounds so
i don't know weak sauce
[Laughter]
she got a thigh master at home they
still sell those
you can probably get them at goodwill
right you guys remember the thigh master
remember they had that [ __ ] um that
infomercial where wasn't [ __ ]
what was her name suzanne summers didn't
she do the thigh master i remember that
right
it was just basically this big hinged
what you call it with like
[ __ ] rubber on it and you just like
stuck it in between your knees and like
squished your
legs together i used to love all those
infomercials man where they
they sell you like this very very
specific like exercise think this very
very specific little part of your body
it's like here's this tiny little thing
for your ab cruncher and here's this
tiny little thing for your thighs you
have to like buy one of each thing
yeah thorn says there are filters to
change body proportions yeah yeah
but not her she's confirmed she does
shows and stuff
so people have seen her yeah yeah she
yeah she's famous
um yes she does have pretty big biceps
um she doesn't weigh that much faster
she doesn't weigh that much though i
think she's maybe
130 140 pounds maybe she's not that big
she's small she got diet master at home
more than that
she was doing like nearly 300 something
pound
[ __ ] squats so she's strong
but um i can just tell by her voice and
some of her physiologies that she's not
within the normal range for a female in
terms of testosterone free testosterone
levels
and there's gonna be some anabolic
steroid use there
you know um but she's exactly what she
wanted to be
she's you know she showed pictures so
you know she hasn't been doing it for
that long
you know four or five years maybe
yeah brittany irwin says i still have an
ab roller lol
what you know what one of my favorite
ones from that era i don't even remember
what they were called maybe somebody can
remember
but um all it was was just
like a plastic step
like you did step aerobics with it and
it was just kind of like hey it's
just like walking upstairs except it's a
plastic step and i'm like dude
you could literally do the same thing
with anything that you could stand on
like i had a big ass [ __ ] webster's
dictionary i'm like i could do the exact
same thing with that for free
so what are you charging me like 19.99
for a piece of like
big thick plastic box that i could step
up and down on
you know what i mean it's just like it
was funny because i remember like right
around
that time when all those infomercials
were really popular yeah the [ __ ] um
mst did like a kind of a little bit of
parody of that and then
they had a thing they did an infomercial
it was called the square master
and it was just this [ __ ] it was like
it was essentially like a larger
mouse pad and they're like look you can
just put it on the floor
and you can like run in place on it or
you can do jumping jacks on it or
whatever
it was just like i was like that's just
about as [ __ ] pointless as the
[ __ ]
but that's kind of what they were making
for zach asking me to go
look at his boy lassie matt berg that's
his ideal man
you want me to go check out your ideal
man i'm gonna i'm gonna
do this yeah he wants your opinion okay
then drop a link in the damn comment
section and i'll check it that way but
i'm looking at dude
victor says she got a thigh master at
home then magnus says those sides are
[ __ ] up
and then dj says [ __ ] him she is the
thigh master
okay
she's really interesting she came from a
muslim family
her dad [ __ ] didn't want her to do
any of this [ __ ]
they kind of disowned her they did not
support any of this [ __ ] she's like [ __ ]
you
she when she went to school and i can't
remember where it was that she went to
school it was somewhere i think in
eastern europe i remember correctly
she got teased for having skinny legs so
she got pissed off and said [ __ ] that
i'm gonna i'm gonna go to the gym and
build some big ass legs
and then i'm gonna crush everyone's head
with you guys in a few
years she got [ __ ] pretty big and
while she was there she's hanging out
with all those [ __ ] muscle heads
so then she kind of gets sucked into
that culture and
uh she gets more and more results and
more and more self-confidence
she starts asking about some of these
[ __ ] chemical modifications that she
could do
she starts getting into kind of like
gothy type stuff and
then she became the buck on aviva that
you know that you know and
she ended up getting a boyfriend here in
[ __ ] florida and she moved to miami
yeah which i didn't i somebody told me
that recently
i showed him to just i showed her to
saad guy in saudi arabia and she's like
he didn't like her first but she goes
yeah i guess she is kind of sexy you
know
and uh because that's not his culture
you know most of these super feminine
women
and i'm like well that's feminine too
it's just a different way of a different
manifestation of femininity
when you put her next to a muscled guy
there's a big difference
big difference in size proportion and
weight she's definitely female she's
just modified you know
i didn't see it as kind of like body
modification
or you know transhumanism type things
where you come in becoming kind of like
a cyborg
it's like that because there's all kinds
of biotech involved
well like i said this is why i never
really had a problem with i know that
there's kind of a thing where people
they you know for a time they had
especially on like all the [ __ ]
stupid ass talk shows they you know
daytime talk shows they used to have and
like then the reality shows that kind of
came later
and i know that there's kind of a thing
like hey look at these freakish people
that get puzzle pieces tattooed
all over their faces or split their
tongue so they look like a snake or
something like that
but it's just kind of like you know a
lot of it it's not what i would choose
and
you know yeah in my opinion some of it
doesn't look good but it's just kind of
like if that's what you want to look
like then
who am i to tell you not to you know
what i mean yeah your body do whatever
the [ __ ]
maniac says kind of like that female orc
in the raid video game
ads i keep seeing jesus it's giving me
issues i don't know who you're talking
about i'm not i'm not geeking out on
female orcs
you know uh [ __ ] i had my time
geeking out on
on female elves back when i was 13 and
14
reading the damn [ __ ] comic book
called elfquest i don't know if
yeah i just thought the animation and
the little elf
warrior women from elfquest i thought
they were just cutest thing ever
but if i probably see it today it
probably would draw like [ __ ] probably
but they kind of had almost like anime
yeah and that wasn't real common in the
united states back then but elfquest
i was in living in california going to
military school at that time
and i was into dnd devs and dragons and
[ __ ] the game
and elfquest comic books are being were
real
popular at my military academy
so yeah that's how i saw him yeah it's
pretty cute neat
i remember seeing some of those i don't
really remember a lot what they looked
like but i remember some being around
the house
elfquest was about you know it's about
wars between elves
in this uh [ __ ]
[Music]
prehistoric land i guess and they rode
around some of them rode around on
wolves
they were almost human-sized but not
quite
you know i think they were like maybe
four foot five five feet tall a lot of
them
and they had a bunch of different tribes
of them they were kind of like
barbarians wore
furs and had uh um
bows and arrows and swords and
everything and i don't remember if they
had magic or not i think maybe they had
some i thought all elves were magic
yeah but it wasn't like it wasn't like
that i think some of them were wizards
and some of them weren't
you know there weren't and there were
humans in it
but the humans were cavemen you know i
mean they were kind of like the bad guys
you didn't see them that often they were
just [ __ ] dudes in the loincloth with
[ __ ]
clubs and what clubs and dragons yeah
and [ __ ] torches and stuff and had to
run from them
so this is like you know neanderthal
times you know
okay that's fair enough that's what was
happening right
they were more advanced than humans but
like i said i haven't seen that
since 1980 81.
david june says uh can confirm elfquest
looks like [ __ ]
like i said i haven't seen it since 81
but that was like
that was like an early prototype of the
stuff that later on
gave rise to the popularity of of um
tolkien stuff you know like the movies
talking movies
yeah it probably looks like [ __ ] but
back in those days that that was kind of
pretty good quality compared to what was
out there
at that time it's just funny to think
about now
because you know now geeks have taken
over the world which like i said i don't
have a problem with that
but um back in the day it's just kind of
like
it's funny to me to think that like
[ __ ] led zeppelin wrote songs about
[ __ ]
tolkien and everybody's like what the
[ __ ] is that what are they talking about
what the [ __ ] are they talking about now
everybody yes and now it's like now
everybody's kind of like make fun of me
like oh it's like so dorky yes
some of the best fantasy art aside from
you know
um frank poseta but you know that we saw
as kids in the very early 80s would be
the stuff out of the
dungeon dragons [ __ ] you know monster
manuals and all the [ __ ]
yeah we had all those all the the
modules and [ __ ] you know i mean i guess
it was gary gygax and some other guys
and errol otis i think was the name of
the artist that drew all that stuff
which by today's standards is probably
real crude looking
so elfquest was el quest i remember it
being about on par
with what was going on in dungeons and
dragons at that time
it was not a time for great art there
was
there were great artists but they were
in [ __ ] like heavy metal magazine
although i have to say i remember the
monster manuals that we had
i remember the art in there being good
but like i said i haven't seen them at
all
in a long time but i do remember the art
in there being like yes
elfquest was maybe a little bit below
that i haven't seen it let me go check
it's just it's just funny to me that
like something that i mean in the 80s
when we were growing up
like if you played dungeon the dragons
or you were into that kind of stuff
everyone was like dork
then you'd get your ass kicked and now
it's just kind of like everybody's into
that [ __ ]
which like i said i don't have a problem
with that i'm glad kind of like
geeks took over the world and i'm pretty
fine with it you know what i'm saying i
don't know
i'm not really all that cool well in the
sense that
[ __ ] that used to be real marginal and
everyone would make fun of you for
liking it now it's just kind of like
everybody likes that [ __ ] yeah it's kind
of mainstream
which sucks in a lot of ways because i
said we've talked about this before too
it's like
that's kind of what happened when you
know kind of
the goth look went mainstream in the 90s
yeah
and then all kind of terrible things
ensued from that
like suddenly it was in all these movies
and [ __ ]
fashion designers were putting that [ __ ]
on the runway and
we were just kind of like ah man so you
know i i can kind of see how that would
that sucked i mean it sucked for us and
like i said look what happened at
[ __ ]
when we talked about columbine and all
that other kind of [ __ ] where
suddenly you get lumped and it was like
the [ __ ] satanic panic all over again
you know what i mean
yeah okay i'm seeing all different kinds
of elfquest
and looks like elfquest existed for a
long time and
went through many variations so
um i'm trying to see which one would
have been the one that
elfquest book one is 50 bucks
um so yeah see i remember that
yeah it kind of looks like crap but that
was
that was kinda i'm gonna show you guys
that's kind of
on par with what we were used to in the
early 80s yeah
it's not that bad not that bad trying to
get it to focus
well don't [ __ ] with it too much are we
going to crash the plane there we go
i totally remember that we might have
had we might have had that right now
wolves and everything
with those little tongue yeah and what
not now see if the stream if the stream
crashes and i'm going to blame you
[Laughter]
we don't have the party lights on for
that very reason yeah
but you know and see it's like i don't
want to jinx it but we've been going for
an hour and 40 minutes and it still
hasn't dropped
so i think that might have been our
problem too much motion in the
background
you know what i'm saying but see i
remember like look up some of the art
from the monster manual because i kind
of feel like
i remember that most of that being nice
but i don't think it was the same
i mean i don't think the same artist did
like the whole book not that i'm
no it was like four or five of them yeah
i thought it was like a bunch of
different i i really enjoyed
the art from that era from dungeons and
dragons and all the books
you know we thought it was really cool
going back at it and looking at it
it was pr i would probably recognize
everything
victor garcia says he's 38 you've never
heard of elfquest
i think elfquest in the time that i
found it like that book one two and
three i think it was book one two and
three is all we had
i think that was around 81 yeah 81.
um that might have been a local
california production
i don't know if that was nationwide but
like i said we had i saw it too
did you yeah okay but he's like younger
like he's like 10 years younger than us
yeah
so maybe it was just kind of like a
thing where california was like a real
had a r was somewhat kind of like an
epicenter of the judges and dragons and
fantasy stuff and all the games
well that's where a lot of the companies
were that's where the companies were and
a lot of them were like
they don't exist anymore um one of them
was a company that sold these lead
figurines of little spaceships they
looked kind of like cross between star
wars
star wars-y looking stuff with one of
them was straight up star trek it was
star trek stuff but it was like a
board game you played on hex maps
between
ships that flew around they were like
war games
and i don't remember what the star trek
one was maybe called star fleets i kind
of feel like they might have played that
on beer and board games
on stage that sounds very familiar the
other ones were
kind of like you had things that looked
like star destroyers and
other weird ships and they all had their
you know they weren't destroyed in one
shot of course you know what i mean you
had to fight they fought each other
forever
hours they were blowing people blowing
themselves apart attacking weapon
systems on them
and these were guys that were much older
than me that were playing these games
you know these are guys that from my
point of view were adults at that time
they were probably in their 20s
20s and 30s they were all fat fat with
beards
and glasses you know they they were not
they were not cool guys by any means in
terms of like you i mean they weren't
the kind of guys that would be
successful in nightclub
they were they were nerds they were real
nerds and in a way they did inherit the
earth because it was dudes like that
that were behind [ __ ] like apple and
microsoft and all you know it was guys
like that
yeah that ended up becoming tech giants
at least some of them did not all of
them
they were the ones that got lucky did
but um
yeah it was at another time it was yeah
i mean i was gonna say too like i don't
know why this reminded me of that but i
guess because you said elfquest but one
of the first
games that i remember being really into
like on the pc back in the 90s
was king's quest do you remember that no
it kind of came on a disc it was like
one of those ones that you got at
[ __ ]
i don't even think we had best buy back
then i don't even remember what the
[ __ ] store was
we bought it and it came like in a big
cardboard box and then it was like all
these [ __ ] discs
the graphics were actually not too bad
um for i want to say it was maybe 96 or
97
and it was just kind of it was like a
fantasy game you know it was kind of
like you'd go
you know you were looking for i don't
even remember what the [ __ ] you were
looking for you look like magical [ __ ]
you know
just kind of like dungeons and dragons
but they couldn't call it that but uh
you know so
i remember that kind of [ __ ] it was kind
of like i don't know
i kind of feel like it was sort of like
legend of zelda also
dj maniac said that that literally looks
like the same art design from the old d
d
cartoon from the 80s yeah it probably
was companies that were all related to
each other
elfquest was probably in some way
related to all that it probably was
um those dudes all knew each other oh my
god dj maniac just said we had battle
chests the pieces would kill each other
i remember that we had that too
yeah that's right media also said rao
partha made those d and d led figures
tsr made the books yeah ralph arthur
made all the figures
i remember this thing there was a couple
of companies that did that and i had a
lot of them the little orcs and the
kobolds and the [ __ ] goblins and
[ __ ] big ass dragons they were all
toxic [ __ ] lead
and you painted them they looked great i
had real good eye
hand coordination back then i didn't
need glasses i could focus in
and paint a little tiny eyes on these
little bitty animals i couldn't do it
today
but yeah even though you might be
laughing on i'd be like painting the
face and
just get a single hair with a little
drop of [ __ ] paint on it
paint knives and stuff i was real
meticulous when i was young i could do
really small fine detail stuff
none of the patience for it now but [ __ ]
when i was [ __ ]
11 12 13 i just
was a [ __ ] master i'd [ __ ] paint
those little figurine little men's
little tiny kobolds and [ __ ]
they're little shields that would just
look [ __ ] like a photograph almost of
a little
of a little monster i was into it
i can mix and paint colors and stuff i
remember being really into i don't know
so you can probably still get these
nowadays but like um when you go to the
craft store and you would buy these
little i guess i don't know if they're
made of like plaster or whatever like
but like little plaster figures of like
different characters and stuff and um
you can buy the paint and like paint
them
i was really into doing that when i was
a kid too and i really liked
when i was really little i really liked
those paint by numbers yeah
uh you know like usually like horses or
landscapes or whatever
i could do model tanks model planes
[ __ ] star trek models
i was airbrushing i could airbrush i
could [ __ ] hand brush you could do
all that kind of [ __ ]
i was good at it back then i haven't
done it forever she got me that model i
haven't built a really good model in a
long long time well that's why i got
that for you and you really need to do
it because
it's like really expensive i gotta
there's a couple things i've got to do
is got to get the paint
and i want to look at the uh the
electronic guts
to see because there's an aftermarket so
the [ __ ] the cells have different
lighting things that you know i want to
do
have the best possible electronic guts
for the thing
i think that the ldd kit looks better
well yeah like the led kit's about 60
bucks
if you're going to do it like do it
right right
and then instead and it has like uh
hundreds of sounds and theme songs that
you can play through the remote
see you need to get that you need to get
that going one of the keys put it in the
background of the show
one of the kits the phaser system in
there the phaser banks on the thing
fire actual real lasers
like these lasers that will actually
laser beam that'll like kill you
nice no but just you know a laser beam
will put
out a phaser yeah i'm gonna put it on
stun by the way yeah
so i gotta look i got there there's a
guy who he's hand
making all those things and so not just
for
that model but for a whole bunch of them
but each one of them is
tailored to that to that ship
you know what i mean yeah so
it looked good because i'm going to put
it back there
well yeah because it's big yeah it's big
and you know the the [ __ ]
those warp nacelles on the front i want
the good effect or it looks just like
out of the movies
yeah where the things are spinning in
there and little running lights and all
the [ __ ] lights okay we'll get it
yeah we'll get all of it it'll look very
cool
victor says jenny did you go through a
horse girl phase i did
i feel like um pretty much i think all
the girls in the 80s maybe i don't know
if it's still going on now but all the
girls in the 80s
70s and 80s went through that kind of
[ __ ] um
so i used to go in daytona we had this
big huge like two or three stories toy
store called dunn toys
and um i would go there every few weeks
every time i had some money
and would buy model horses so i had a
whole [ __ ] ton of model horses i don't
know what happened to them my mom might
still have them in the attic for all i
know
um but yeah i had a bunch of those and
like i said i used to
do a lot of paint by number kits and a
lot they weren't all horses i did other
[ __ ] too but
um i did do a lot of horses and of
course everybody knew that i was into
that [ __ ] so
they would give me like horse [ __ ] not
actual horse [ __ ] but just like
[ __ ] with horses on it no maniac made a
model of um
crustal as i guess snake pliskin
probably no i didn't see it man if i can
send me a send me a
link on facebook or something i'll check
it out
i was actually thinking about making a
couple of dolls
because you can buy the stuff to make a
doll
i wanted to make a [ __ ] kurt russell
[ __ ] snake pliskin doll
because you can get all that the clothes
the head
you can get a kurt russell head and
paint that getting kurt russell's head
painted with the [ __ ] eye patch and
everything that's kind of bootleg
because that's copyrighted yeah but they
got guys with 3d print printers
making fake heads you put it on the body
and then the clothes
i want to make that and i wanted to make
a uh
uh neville colonel neville from
um omega man yeah i wanted to do that
with the mk
760 machine gun and his flight suit and
his [ __ ] colonel's hat and his
[ __ ]
glasses and [ __ ] getting ready to kill
some damn zombies
they're not zombies vampires i guess
mutant vampires yeah they're mutant
vampires
yeah we need to be you could probably
you could start a whole [ __ ] etsy
store doing that yeah making making
dolls action figure men call him action
figure but i know it's a doll
thank you victor for the horse for the
horseshit fun
[Laughter]
i know i really did i had a lot of i had
a lot of
different horses like i don't even
remember what most of those were made of
but they were they were really cool i
had a couple that were ceramic
and then somebody gave me like some
barbie ones like barbie was supposed to
ride on it but of course that bitch's
legs didn't go
her [ __ ] legs don't go in the way
that your legs have to go to ride a
horse
frugal videographer asked me if i could
make a cigar doll that you're
you're inspiring me because they got
different bodies
can he be fat yes they have different
stuff they're they're
they're a bunch of the bodies are in
body type
size lean fat whatever so you can
construct they're all
different you know scale they're all the
same scale
but you can get them in different
heights and stuff like tall and fat
all right um but yeah you could do a fat
steven seagal
because you can get that head i've seen
somebody selling
a fat steven seagal head
if you make it yeah you have to make it
so that he can't stand up
you have to make it so that he's just
sitting down sitting down yeah
and then he's dead well i was thinking
oh my god
i was thinking about kind of an
overlapping
i was thinking about an overweight cigar
in the black silk pajamas with the
[ __ ] red silk chinese shirt
see yes with the [ __ ] sunglasses with
his black round
sunglasses within his goatee yeah with
his best [ __ ] braid
where he's being [ __ ] just culturally
appropriate and like
[ __ ] crazy you know what i mean
seagull was that [ __ ] don't get
me on that
whatever race he had to be for any given
um
[ __ ] um interview one minute he's
doing a fake chinese accent
next minute he's doing a black accent
next minute he's southern
man he's from michigan and he's jewish
yeah
yeah i mean he's just whatever
[ __ ] seagull he's the fascinating man
he seems completely unaware of his
own bullshitter now he knows that's why
he's trying to keep a low profile
and all those women running after him
from charges sexual assault charges
yeah why does that not [ __ ] surprise
me he seems exactly the type of person
that would do that kind of thing you got
like 20 [ __ ] kids
and uh and and like most of them most of
them girls and most of them good looking
and they're wrong so they must have said
they must have all taken after their
mothers then
yeah i guess and they're uh
they're up there in russia with him i
think they're with from russian women
you know uh ones that he paid to like
rush the sex slaves for a while but our
sex employees on staff sex sex employees
sex employees on staff to serve as every
whim but he had the money
and they were willing you know it's uh
well i don't know if they were so much
willing they're like well
they're workers i want to eat and i need
money they're hookers
yeah they're hookers you know and they
they could be worse they had a [ __ ]
contract
and a service contract that way they
only got to sell it to one dude instead
of 20 dude
or 100 dudes so i don't know they're
hookers i don't know how much money
you'd have to pay
the thing is though look steven seagal
could probably lie
you know he definitely can lie his ass
off and if you're not hearing these lies
in your own native tongue
maybe they're more believe more and more
because
you're some you know chick from chechnya
or something you know who's [ __ ]
never had a pot to piss in and this
guy's an american movie star you don't
really speak the same language he does
and fraus you know this [ __ ] is
just straight up legit
you know yeah so you probably you yeah
kind of star struck
yeah yeah that's probably yo he's got
all these people he's got money and he's
got money
in movies and he's he's good to me so he
must not be completely full of [ __ ]
yeah you also don't know where these
girls are coming from you know what i
mean some came from this was in a time
when there was a lot of
uh eastern european women running from
[ __ ]
bad war-torn areas yeah so someone was
like maybe
poverty yeah so i think this might have
been a step up
zach said the cigal doll should have an
inflatable belly
and as an accessory a can of asian
experience yeah
yeah yeah you can make a little tiny
yeah he could come with that now the
dolls have solid bellies
you can get them they're made but
they're fully articulated
wait the belly is fully articulated
it's just like any other action figure
i'll show you you know what i mean
there's a way to make
fat ones like that but they're still
fully articulated
i put him in the chinese outfit
silk outfit something like that and i
try maybe
try to make a little small can of asian
experience i mean yeah cool
that'd be pretty cool that's a good idea
thanks for thanks for inspiring me maybe
one of them i'm putting on a list
and honestly you know how you know how
like with what i do is [ __ ] make some
of
them
sell these [ __ ] over the show that's
what i'm saying
like i said you can have a whole [ __ ]
etsy store yeah as long as you didn't
know
all of what their name was you could
call them like
you know um you could call it like
martial artist movie star
yeah right yeah like everybody would
know who it was but you couldn't and
then that way maybe you wouldn't get
sued i don't know you have to look into
the legality
but yeah you could probably do direct
sales though over or you could probably
do some direct sales though
just online exactly the same probably
okay there it is okay
i'll send it to you like i said as long
as it's not a mass product
it's not a mass production item yeah you
know
i don't know like i said you're getting
into like weird like legal territory
when you're making money on something
like that like on somebody like a famous
person's image
maybe so i mean it's not like they what
you do
if you found the body you don't sell in
the head then later on
sold separately later later on for free
yeah i'm sure there's like loopholes and
ways to work around it
but it's just kind of like i was
thinking too that you remember how like
back in the day
they might still do this but like with
barbies and all that kind of [ __ ] where
they would sell you like an environment
like it's the barbie dream house or it's
the barbie corvette or what the [ __ ]
ever
i think that you should also sell little
environments
for your steven scala dolls yeah listen
read what [ __ ] soap you said
you should do like a little pool that's
full of asian experience
no we were so i wanted to buy tom one of
the cigar bobble heads they made for his
law man show but that [ __ ] goes for
hundreds on ebay now
believe it or not [ __ ] seagull uh
memorabilia
is worth a lot of [ __ ] money well i
think a lot of novelty
yeah well look at the guy that one guy i
can't remember what his name is but that
other guy that's on uh cinematic or
sometimes
that dude collects steven seagal's stuff
like ironically
yeah and he has every [ __ ] steven
seagal thing
ever yeah thank you nico cat glad i
caught the show i've had to miss out on
a few
yeah we're glad you're here too yeah he
has all the [ __ ]
yeah um i i looked up uh asian
experience
and there were people selling unopened
cans of asian experience for several
hundred dollars
again because it's it's almost all gone
well yeah they don't make it anymore
yeah
but uh yeah i opened it opened it and
tried it
well that was that was the same guy that
was the guy that was on center massacre
they had
he was talking about his steven seagal
collection because he showed a lot of it
on there he
was everything it was way beyond
expiration date too it was what 11 years
11 years at least he said it wasn't that
good
said it was true he probably wasn't that
good he said
he was drinkable but he could he
he he wasn't sure whether or not age had
something to do with it
yeah it's like it might just tasted like
ad right just right out of the [ __ ]
gate
because like i said it's an energy drink
like right and they all
was wise he would relaunch asian
experience
although you know what maybe it's only
cool because it's old now
see that's the thing i don't know if it
would work if you actually tried to
seriously yeah
people i think people only like that
kind of stuff for the irony value and
the fact that it's old and it's gone
because it's old and it's cheesy and
nobody makes it anymore
yeah maybe so that's the thing it's
it's like i feel like i don't know like
some companies are kind of like oh we
saw this thing and it's like really
popular but then they try to make a new
version of it and nobody wants that [ __ ]
because that's not why they want it
a [ __ ] drink is called asian
experience
it's obviously a [ __ ] sexual
connotations to the [ __ ]
and that [ __ ] released it are we
having anybody's experience we're gonna
have it
no baby you know i love you you're not
sure
but but but steve
i wanted to have the asian experience oh
you could pour that down that pool would
just fill the whole pool up with the
asian experience i'll drink every bit of
it baby
i drink every bit of it baby that's
[ __ ] crazy [ __ ] man
he he called the drink asian experience
yeah
yeah he did he had like a well he'll
look at it this way he could have called
it punani yeah punani nani
asian puna asian punani that could have
called it that
he could have called it he should have
called it that he should have called it
maybe maybe yeah if he re-releases it
that's what he should call it
punani asian poonami
yeah i like to read i'm
back by popular demand
i know the asian experience is selling
for several hundred dollars
a bottle on on ebay
so i'm gonna go ahead and i'm gonna
re-release asian experience but this is
going to be asian experience too
it's going to be even better i'm going
to rename this
this batch should be called asian poo 99
[Laughter]
oh my god this is for you guys that have
never had that asian experience i'm
gonna give it to you in the can
it's gonna be beautiful that asian
experience yeah
you can just sit back watch somebody
asian porn and drink some of this asian
poo now
it's like virtual virtual porn
quenching your thirst at the same time
porn in the can giving you all kinds of
nutrients
and what's another one today but
tannerine now all these [ __ ] what are
all those weird hokey [ __ ] things
that they put in asia
ginger in there too probably yeah i
don't know you'll be able to be able to
jump up and fight anybody when you get
done drinking some of that you're
slapping with your dick
seven people around
for some reason i was just reminded of
back in the late 90s
where i used to work there was a guy
that i used to work with
and he got into a thing where there was
a drink
i think it was only very briefly
available but it was
what somebody who said stephanie seagal
that's been steven seagal's daughter
stephanie okay
that's [ __ ] funny dude but um yeah so
i guess it was like pretty
briefly available but there was this was
it
i don't know if it was like bottled
water or if it was like some kind of
energy drink or something but it came in
like this blue
like this really nice blue bottle but it
kind of looked like a
um it had like all these little knobs on
the outside like it looks like one of
those weird
[ __ ] ribbed dildos or whatever so the
bottle kind of looked
like that and it was called balls
i don't know it might have been i don't
i think it was sparkling water i want to
say
but he so he had like he would bring
that in every day so he had like this
big collection of
blue bottles like up on the on the shelf
over his desk and it was just and
it said balls but it's just the bottle
looks like
kind of like a dildo but i guess they
did it on purpose was this
the guy i used to work with oh okay it's
just i don't even know if anybody
remembers that [ __ ] but they i think it
was sparkling water it might have been
an
energy drink but it was like a blue
bottle that looked like a dildo and it
was called balls
i feel like that was kind of a big thing
back in the 90s or whatever like there
was some [ __ ] that they were selling i
think it's in the late late
80s early 90s it was it came in like a
real
fancy blue bottle and floating in it
were like these little balls of gelatin
remember that oh yeah you could drink it
yeah the name of that [ __ ] i don't know
so you might remember you want another
drink
yeah well i kind of feel like they did
that recently too isn't that what that
[ __ ] [ __ ] is that
boba tea or whatever the [ __ ] yeah with
like all the custard bubbles like
floating bubbles floating in
the little balls of gelatin and they
were shiny they look like they had
glitter in them
ooh pretty kind of reminds me like those
[ __ ] bath beads or whatever
i don't know i never really got into
that and i feel like
i don't know it just seems like kind of
a crowded market there's so many
so many energy drinks there's so many
because it's at some point it seemed
like everybody was trying to jump on
that [ __ ] bandwagon because the
[ __ ] market share was so
large and i think that's probably why
steven seagal thought that he could
make that [ __ ] fly because everybody had
a [ __ ] energy drink back then
and only a few brands actually stood the
test of time i'm pretty sure that balls
isn't around anymore
yeah see dj maniac remembered balls and
it was yeah b-a-w-l-l-s
the bottle was nice like i said but it
was indeed ripped for her pleasure
at least that's how i remember it i was
like that looks like a [ __ ]
that looks like like a textured dildo
but that's what it was supposed to look
like i suppose
but i don't know he just brought one of
those in every day and then he had like
this whole big long [ __ ]
a whole big long row of them
no but what i was saying is that if tom
is going to do that he should totally
make little playsets
for all of his figures because
you could do well i mean
obviously you could do the asian
experience pool playset
you know with the chick inside the pool
you could do that
you could do an under siege play set
with like a little ship and like a
little kitchen with like some [ __ ]
you can check on punk with some [ __ ]
gumbo or something like
that in the pot you could do that
and then obviously like for the snake
pluskin one you could have the [ __ ]
little escape from new york set you know
what i mean like with a little crash
plane and
i don't know maybe i'm overthinking it i
don't know i just like that idea
you know because i have this one um
i have this really cool figure i don't
know if it's i think it's way up there
and i can't reach it
but it's um it's dr jekyll and mr hyde
and the dr jekyll is kind of little but
like the
mr hyde like kind of snaps over him
because the mr hyde figure is like
really big so the dr jekyll is inside
but you can take them as
you can kind of snap it apart and then
like
you know so dr jekyll is inside
but it comes with like a little play set
so it has like this little
stone wall in the back and it all snaps
together and then there's like a little
lab table
and then there's like all this little
[ __ ] that you can put on his uh little
table it's got like little beakers and
like a little book about transformation
or whatever
there's like a little candle and all
this other kind of [ __ ] it's really cool
i don't even remember where i got it
from yeah it's up there i can't reach it
though we have like this there's like a
little shelf above the closet and it's
like way up there on the top and i can't
get to it
plus i have little bitty um i have
little bitty figures of
uh freddy and jason and leatherface
they're only like this big though
and they have like little bitty tiny
environments
like the leatherface one has like a
little vice
and a little stone floor with blood all
over it and then
the freddy one has like a little round
thing like a boiler door
and then the jason one like the bottom
is like kind of grass and then it has
like a little sign that says camp
crystal lake on it
but you know those are really cool i
don't know i just said i think i said
this before but i really like that's why
i like designing board games is because
i like a whole thematic thing that all
goes together
you know i mean so that's why i like the
idea of like having these little figures
and all this little kind of like
[ __ ] that you can put them in the
seagull sex dungeon playset
i don't really want to have to imagine
that dj maniac says
i make custom action figures vehicles
and playsets is my main hobby i haven't
gotten around to making you and tom just
yet though
oh my god wouldn't that be cool i kind
of want little action figures of us
with like a little playset i don't know
what our little playset would be
hmm pookie would have to be in it though
and beijing i don't know
i kind of feel like our play set would
be kind of boring
it's just like this room with like party
lights in it
with a baby yoda in the background or
some [ __ ] like that mcfarlane's monsters
i remember these from the late 90s
yeah it's like i have i think another
one that i have
too i can't remember where it went to
but um
i have one i think that like they did
like a clive barker line
if i'm remembering it correctly and i
had one that was called what the [ __ ]
was it called it was like clyde barker's
carnival of horrors or whatever the hell
it was called and it's like so there's
one and it's like there's all these
figures just like a little
like deformed baby in a jar and like all
this other kind of [ __ ]
but i have that too someplace around
here and i have like a little
oh i have this is right here it's like
but i haven't opened it yet but
i have this is a little egg around the
pope figure
see i have that there
and i have a couple frankenstein monster
ones as well
but yeah i love post stuff and i don't
know if i've showed you guys this but
i just got this not too long ago i'm
just like scared to use it because i'm
not gonna put it in the dishwasher or
anything but check this [ __ ] out
this is my edgar allen poe
mug look at that look how [ __ ] cool
that is
i saw it on amazon and i was like oh i
gotta have that
but like i said i almost kind of don't
want to use it like i've
been keeping it in the box because i
like it too much to mess it up
like all my [ __ ] all my [ __ ] toys
that i have uh
yeah see yeah you have to make a pookie
in a beijing when you make tom and jenny
yeah we have to have our little kids on
there
i've been trying to do like one idea
that i had for a new
t-shirt design is i wanted to do kind of
like
little like caricature kind of cartoons
of us and of
pookie in beijing and it's just kind of
like well
i could i could draw it might take a
long time
or i could like maybe find some
character art that kind of looks like us
i don't know it's i'll think of
something
but that was one idea that i had because
i really like the idea of
like having like cartoons of us and then
like with the little kitties like
sticking out on the side
i don't know that's just one of the
ideas that i'm kind of throwing around
um beezness says jenny can you wear my
t-shirt if it comes before your show
friday oh i absolutely will
i absolutely will um
we'll see we'll see if it comes before i
mean what is it it's wednesday right
yeah
so it'll probably be here like you said
i'm excited to see what it is
i just recently i had a bunch of uh
coupons for zazzle so i said well [ __ ]
i'm gonna go back in and buy one of our
own shirts so i bought one of my
who is summerton man shirts i wore it
the other day but you couldn't really
see it much
where did you find her couldn't find her
uh-oh even looked out there by the
by the pond didn't see her i wonder
where she went
i got i got the feeling she's either in
the bushes next door she went underneath
the damn
fence and looking at the trail she
better not be under you know she is
she's a cat she does what she wants
maybe she's by the neighbor's house
probably we'll see
it's not dark yet oh yeah
it's not crazy that's what's crazy it's
like i'm in this office so much
yeah and i like darkness you know so
i have a window right there but i always
keep the curtains closed
and i always keep like the lights pretty
much just like this so it's kind of like
dim in here which i enjoy
um so when i'm in here sometimes i lose
track of time
and then when i glance over at the
window i'm like oh my god it's still
[ __ ] chilling outside it's like for
some reason i thought it was like 10
o'clock at night or whatever
you need to talk now because i've been
talking oh you're right and i have to
well no i have to go to them can't okay
yeah go ahead i gotta i'm gonna go
to the bathroom go ahead and go i'm just
catching up with the uh with the
commentary on the back yeah like you
know
seeing what everybody's saying you were
gone a long time yeah i had went all
around the house three times and i
walked down there to the damn pond and
came back i didn't see her
yeah she's she's scared she's scared now
she's like a mom
like a mother cat's gonna be fine
yeah i just went underneath that i
didn't care what i need to fancy
underneath the fence on the other side
there's a damn walking trail and she
sits out there and watches people walk
by
but uh
yeah so what do you guys have any
questions what's the topic what do we
want to talk about
sorry maniac's trying to make an action
figure me and jenny one of these days
that's funny
they're in there talk about action
figures yeah this the cigal action
figure was a good idea
i should probably i should probably look
into that
even to god did you say i was like a mom
because i'm worried about people
yeah we're about to get to it that cat's
gonna be fine that cat's grown and not
grown up enough he knows what's going on
she better be yeah my
that's my little child there yeah
so what what are we talking about steven
seagal still yeah that's about it
i told you we need to do an asian
experience pool play set
take up all the room in the dab house
well no it could be it's like miniature
you know what i mean actually just going
back on youtube and seeing that
commercial just [ __ ] had me laughing
you know like and that was enough like
revisited in that for a few minutes
and then like i went on youtube not on
youtube on um
ebay and there was people selling
steven seagal memorabilia and
merchandise from his karate tours and
stuff
all right sorry and there was one that i
i shared with uh with sophie i don't
remember what it was it was a little
poster
and it's and it has a picture a black
and white picture of cigar it was like
something that you actually xeroxed it
was like a xerox poster
and he was gonna come he's gonna come
and get some kind of a
some kind of speech about martial arts
the lord
and hell yeah
and it's got a picture of steven seagal
dressed up as as a buddhist monk i guess
with some prayer beads and his hands
together and he's just going
oh my god seriously yeah he's got a
prayer bees wrapped in his hand
and it says you know master steven
seagal
uh teaching blah blah blah blah and it
says the location and the time
and underneath it it had like a [ __ ]
generic wise man quote from steven
seagal
i can't remember exactly what it was
dude get the [ __ ] off
yeah and it was like oh my god it was
like one of those
deepak chopra quotes where which
sounds deep as [ __ ] until you think
about it and you're like serious
if it's still there somebody please go
to the deepak chopra like
quote generator it is hilarious yeah
and i guarantee you will not be able to
tell the difference between what that ai
coughs up and what he actually said i'm
gonna see if i can try to find what his
[ __ ] quote
is when i when i [ __ ] read it out you
what i'll tell you guys the quote
you'll [ __ ] laugh because it's not
much to it i'm gonna try to see what it
is
uh okay so david june asked tell us what
you're playing these days tom also
zach asks can there be a david miscavige
action figure
oh i like that idea that's good that's a
good idea yeah i like that
um and then david june again says i
think the tom
action figure should come with grits
[Laughter]
what game am i playing dj maniac said he
was going to make some action figures of
us
i said make some action figures of us
and pookie and beijing and yeah you can
have a bowl of grits as your
accessory what would my accessory be
i don't know what my accessory would be
i can't think of an accessory
i don't know maybe somebody can think of
a good one i'm trying to go through the
quotes
uh there's a lot of quotes
i'm trying to see
there's a lot of people in there there's
a lot of bullets that yeah
um i kind of feel like i mean deepak
chopra and like people of that
ilk i feel like that's kind of like
their whole bread and butter is just
like saying
[ __ ] that sounds deep until you think
about it yeah yeah yeah
so he wants to know what what i'm
playing i was playing um
i'm doing far harbor off of um that's
fallout yeah
fall out yeah isn't that i like the love
crafty and it's kind of
lovecraftian of it look it feels like it
but once you start playing it it's not
it does have some sea monsters in there
but far harbor
um i still kind of mess around with uh
um metal gear solid
five yeah you seem to be really liking
that yeah i got tired of that one had to
come off of it though
um started to get kind of repetitive and
then um
i got uh this
the star wars [ __ ] flying one i think
it might be it's not rogue squadron
it might be rogue squad it's one of the
newer flying one it's all right
and uh i was going through an old retro
game called two rock two
i got about halfway through it and i got
stuck so i stopped playing that i got to
go back and figure that i missed a
key or something somewhere to unlock a
level
and then um trying to think what else i
was playing
i like all the tomb raider games i got
them all for xboxes i'll
kind of go through this every now and
then i'll revisit like tomb raider i
kind of like watching those too yeah i
guess they're trying to really climb
the music is kind of relaxing also yeah
dj maniac said maybe the quote was a
naked man fears no pickpocket
no no it's um
[Laughter]
see if i can find it it was on youtube
man i believe in you
i believe in you stream
you can do you're gonna have to yeah
you're gonna have to reset am i
i think so no it's back is it
it's back on yeah
i don't trust it it's [ __ ] it's a
trip man i don't trust him it's back
maybe we moved around too much no i
don't think that's what it is because
we've been
streaming for a long time two hours and
19 minutes yeah that's a long time
yeah but i mean some of the shows we've
done are like [ __ ] three hours i
don't know it's
jail crashed no the last couple we've
done haven't
and they've gone like three or four
hours as soon as it starts doing that
lets you know it's getting ready to
crash
well yeah that's what i keep telling but
you were like no no no it's back home i
was like no i know how it goes it's back
off
okay um we'll see yeah but did they ask
me something else
i don't remember yeah yes yeah that
happened because
seagal got pissed off
[Laughter]
every time we start [ __ ] on steven
seagull stevenson all controls the
internet hell yeah shut that [ __ ] down
i like that doesn't i don't like that
[Laughter]
could be they're destroying my image
my public image is a very good image and
they keep [ __ ] my image over
we've got to stop that before the world
turns against me
oh my god i still would hate to lose my
career
i mean i guess he has a career of a sort
yeah i mean he's still making movies
kind of he yeah he's making more movies
than i'm making oh it crashed again yeah
he has he has uh he has fans
he's got a fan base it's weird sure
you know yeah it's not crash down here
okay well we're just gonna keep on
talking yeah
and then like i said like i really like
i also like zach's idea that we can make
it just
david miscavige action figure yeah we'll
just make him like really really small
be a small one with a little beast
that'd be really funny
gotta do he'll be really really tiny
david miscavige
and tom cruise as scientologists yeah
yeah we'll do a whole scientology line
you know there's scientology [ __ ]
suits with the [ __ ] metals
can we do it oh can we do an lrh one too
like with the big [ __ ] fish lips
yeah [ __ ] i don't think you can find
that head
you'd have to have somebody make it well
yeah you could have somebody sculpt the
head
and he could have like the big lips
sticking out he could put him on the
freewinds
i don't think they sculpt them i think
they scan them
scan a photograph in a computer program
i mean to be honest it might be easier
to do like a lego figure like because
then you can just like paint it on there
kind of
a scavenge would be the way to go if you
could get that head
well he just looks like i mean to me he
just kind of looks like generic white
guy
no he doesn't you know what i mean no he
doesn't that's in your mind
he looks like he's well he looks like
evil generic
yeah he's he's weird-looking like a bad
guy in an 80s he looks like
he looks like the dude who starred
in in the um scientology movie
battlefield earth you know the the
little caveman guy
he looked like that i think i think they
chose that
doesn't like him because he looked like
david miscavige
i can't remember what that guy looked
like have i ever even sat through that
whole movie all the way through i don't
think i have
i don't have the patience for that kind
of [ __ ] i actually like that movie
i like that of course i think that movie
is hilarious i'd like to buy it out on
blue well it is hilarious but not
it wasn't supposed to be hilarious
evidently
everyone they got very offended when
people just thought it was funny
i guess the movie has to be serious
battlefield earth had problems first
the first problem is that it was a movie
[ __ ]
made by scientology which people at all
were already turned against it
especially in hollywood
okay people in hollywood all were
already gonna [ __ ] laugh at that
movie all right so that didn't help it
didn't have any friends
in the regular [ __ ] world you know
what i mean non-scientologists
you know and this was at a time when
things about scientology were coming to
light
the timing wasn't all that good
it had kind of bad cg for the time
it did it wasn't rock bottom
but it wasn't like the cg from uh
from a [ __ ] full-scale top-notch
hollywood movie of the day yeah i mean
i've certainly seen worse
but i've seen a lot better too
well they were touting this movie as
like a an all-star
studded [ __ ] science fiction release
to rival star wars and it's like and
we're scientologists so obviously it's
going to be the best thing ever to be
the best thing ever and it's
and we're talking about star wars
[ __ ] a new hope they think it's going
to beat that
yeah okay it's an lrh story he wasn't a
great
science fiction writer really at all
actually he wasn't a great science
fiction writer
and i haven't read any of his stuff but
people say that it's it's it's very
pedestrian
that there's nothing really unusual
about it and it's just pulp
it's pulp writing yeah which like i said
nothing wrong with that but he wasn't
like anything special
some of the artwork that frisetta did in
association
with with with you know frank frazetta
did some
battlefield earth posters and the
posters looked cool as [ __ ] but i think
that was early 80s maybe late 70s
he did that no i don't know i think so
might it might have been
might have been later i think it was i
think it was i think it was early 80s i
i i'm not sure
but i think it was older and it was not
for this movie
and there was you know some of the early
drawings of the way battlefield earth
was supposed to look looked kind of cool
cyborg wookie looking things and big
[ __ ] giant people and
big giant aliens and kind of like a
flash gordon
kind of a thing
anyway when it came to executing the
movie it just uh
it had some strength and some weaknesses
i really liked uh
i really liked some of the alien
technology that they showed
they could put you in a chair and it
would shoot out rays into your eyes
and you could talk to some kind of in
old [ __ ] slave that they
enslaved off another planet an alien
slave that's there to teach you
the let the language of their masters
and [ __ ]
the superior high language of the
something or other i don't remember the
name
yeah you know the [ __ ] badass the
badasses that conquered earth you know
and there was a lot of little details
and a lot of little world making things
that were
kind of good about the movie the aliens
were highly corporate
and um but what's funny about it is if
you understand scientology real well
science the the evil aliens
have a lot in common with scientology
but then the poor humans who are like
cavemen reduce the cavemen they have
nothing to do with scientology
but somehow science this scientology
story is telling you
that if you become a scientologist you
can become freed from these evil
corporations
scientology is an evil corporation yeah
you know but it's more
a lot of that is is is because
lrh was an ex-military officer
came out of the cold war knew a lot
about marxism and communism
he researched a lot about [ __ ] mind
control stuff that the soviets are doing
and the united states were doing he was
also a [ __ ] artist
and he could kind of mix it all together
and he knew that a good
attack is to claim
claim to be exactly what you aren't in
other words if you're an oppressive
evil corporation
claim that everyone else is a is an
oppressive project
projection so that's how scientology
gets into you
because it projects it pretty much like
those those are the bad guys
we're not like that we're not like that
those are the bad ones
they're trying to enslave not us
and that's that's how they get you right
and
that's the common that's the tactic
in [ __ ] psychological warfare so
and you know the chinese were big into
with like maoism they had maoist kind of
mind control going on and he you know
lrh was he was a nerdy he'd geek out on
all that [ __ ] so they
they understood propaganda and
scientology is a [ __ ]
it's a huge beautiful monument to
[ __ ] corporate propaganda
they're just not super good at it
because not even like everybody can see
them not anymore
but no i think they were very good at it
it was they might have been good they
were very good at it until the age of
the internet
because with the internet victims of the
establishment
of this thing could could communicate
with other victims
and they could figure out what the mo
was and bring that to light to the
general public
so before you got involved with
scientology you just check
scientology's rep online and you're
going to find out what scientology is
so it lost its camouflage well and i
think a lot of people too i mean there's
been a lot of studies done
since the 70s on cults and how they work
yeah
and you know a lot of cults work in
pretty much exactly the same
way yeah because humans are the same
pretty much the world over so it's like
all of the tactics they use are pretty
similar
yeah um so i think that the more people
understood that and the more that
information began to be disseminated um
it was harder for them to but here they
get to hide but here's the more
terrifying thing of that when you really
kind of analyze scientology
yeah it's a hokey pyramid scheme
bait that that comes at you
like a spiritual school kind of like the
jedi where you lev
you're leveling [ __ ] up you're
turning the [ __ ] into a wizard
or turning a [ __ ] into a jedi
it's also a ufo call that's what that's
that's
its attack on you yeah right that's what
it uses on you
but that's not really what it is the
entire
organization in a way is a copy
of a state intelligence organization
all right it's a lot like a state
intelligence organization
is what it is they have their own
intelligence organization so it's kind
of like
the kgb or the cia or something and
what's weird is that
the intelligence organizations a lot of
times recruit cults to work for them
totally documented especially in central
and south america up here in the united
states they were doing it
because they'll get a cult to do its
dirty work for you
for an intelligence organization same
thing they will they'll deal with
drug cartels too same [ __ ] thing
um so a lot of this particular cult
modeled itself after an intel a military
or a paramilitary or a government type
of
intelligence organization
weird but so did so did howard hughes's
personal security that's another thing
you look at yeah
howard hughes's personal security
modeled itself
after the fbi and the cia
just to watch his girlfriends the weird
[ __ ] and and um he had so much money and
was defending his empire he got better
than the fbi the fbi couldn't crack his
security
um which goes to show you that if you
have money
and good leadership and focus you can
beat any government
well the thing about it though is that
it's like so like you said he had
the money and he also had the focus yeah
he didn't have to worry about like
all these different things like to keep
track of and it's like we have to like
you know
thin out our resources to take care of
this thing he didn't have anything to
take care of except for his own
self-interest
yeah though the fact that he could spend
all his money doing that
meant that you know obviously
that you know that he wasn't going to be
able to be [ __ ] beat
on that in that right yeah but in the
cold
war coming out of military academies
being in the military watching the
collapse of the soviet union
finding out everything about how the
[ __ ] years following
what the rush what it was really like
um really [ __ ] that was peanuts
compared to [ __ ] that's around today
it's peanuts it's in the late 80s
that i remosted it they had some kind of
a hearing women came forward
i think women came forward that said
that they were in the
uh column he could adopt a foster care
system they were in the foster care
system
as sent to these compounds where they
were them and turned them into sex
underage sex operatives and then um
evidently a lot of them were killed and
everything on it and they evidently paid
the women off and they
vanished and it was something that the
intelligence agencies would they would
entrap it dang and remember that case
where mq
these women from infections i found it
on youtube they actually had like a
senate hearing
these women testified in front of the
senate there was like three of them
with their attorneys and told the whole
story
the senate didn't say [ __ ] they didn't
even fight against what they said
they just said thank you and they paid
them off and now that whole case got
memory hold
but they paid them off it settled with
them so you know it happened
and it was something having to do with
the int what i was saying is
and there's a is that the american
intelligence agencies going back into
the cold war
starting off in the 50s they were much
worse than the kgb
much worse in the kgb was bad but they
these guys were more scientific about
this evil it had to do with mind control
mind control and um getting dirt on
people
and and black money i mean you know
looking
doing [ __ ] with poppy fields in
afghanistan and
weird stuff and uh weird stuff happening
in central america with the [ __ ]
contras and the
with the contras down there in nicaragua
and with uh cocaine trade and stuff
because you see
you have to have untraceable money to do
a lot of these special operations so
the black what's called black funding
has a lot to do with it in other words
they're involved with drug trafficking
and to get to raise the
this invisible funding that they need to
do these
special operations in the name of
national security
but let me ask you this is it really
national security or are they just lined
in their pockets with it
you know what i mean i imagine it's
probably the second thing oh yeah they
give you that power and everything and
now you have the power to get free money
that's totally untraceable
that would corrupt a lot of people
that'd be a great government gig to have
so now you have these guys to have the
ability to [ __ ] bust down your doors
accuse you of a crime take all your
[ __ ] property say you're a drug
dealer plant drugs did on you
and then vanish your [ __ ] ass into a
privately owned prison somewhere in
goddamn romania
as a terrorist and then they pocket all
your [ __ ] and you
and no accountability you know what i
mean it's just
it's it's it's dangerous well [ __ ] man
that's been going on for [ __ ]
centuries that's what they used to do to
like the women they did in the [ __ ]
witchdrive yeah
yeah it's what it goes so she's we're
gonna like sh yeah we're gonna like
[ __ ] torture and then we're gonna
like take all our [ __ ]
take all our [ __ ] so what i'm saying is
that there hasn't really been progress
only the illusion of progress and the
crimes are a lot more sophisticated now
and i think people are slowly kind of
waking up to this we haven't crashed
right no because my [ __ ] crashed over
here
no we're good like my like my streaming
uh thing is still going
with all the comments i can't yeah so i
can't see anybody's
i can't see the chat at this point read
that nope
okay you just you tell me if there's
like anything going on that i know he's
this
top trt went airborne man shut the [ __ ]
up
he's infecting everyone with that [ __ ]
okay so tom put in a comment you guys
are down oh no we're back
e rich listeners want to donate uh
a bomb ass laptop to them
they're going yeah i'm broke you know
yeah they might buy some uh
recon earbuds let's see what people do
straw dog says cia equals the department
of dirty deeds yeah black operations
you know it's black for a reason because
the shit's illegal
uh they're talking about the military uh
this
is also did everyone hit the like button
yet don't forget yeah i gotta hit the
like button
there yeah hit the like button well
thank you see we have to remind you
every single time i can't do it because
it's like oh
okay it's just chat's still going yeah
it kind of well i lost
i lost it but my my [ __ ] my streaming
program is still going my obs
is still going every now and then it
stops
but i lost a lot of viewers with that
last kind of stumble
they went from 50 down to 35 because a
lot of people thought they're like ah
we're losing them they left
yeah yeah well honestly though i'm glad
i didn't like
you know restart the [ __ ] to do because
it did come back
yeah but i don't know like i said i lost
my chat like my youtube just kind of
went black
over there yeah um you know so i don't
know do you have anything else you would
like to discuss
not really i mean we've been chatting
for hours i mean it's almost three hours
yeah we can let people go and i feel
like i'm almost at the bottom of my
third drink
you're not going to go get pookie we
gotta go find pookie it's starting it's
not
quite dark yet but it's good to see you
guys looking um
tea man go see red sun on the [ __ ] [ __ ]
all that [ __ ] zack snyder cut man
that's supposed to be a great movie but
that shit's [ __ ] what three hours
long
just like we said earlier that you
should like just wear your depends
where am i dan what's going on you know
the the adult diapers
why because the movie is really long and
you can't leave in
[Music]
you as in everyone right should wear
depends because yeah
he's really long well no you can just
pause that [ __ ] go take a peek
take a piss and come back out yeah i'm
saying like well back in the old days
when you
had to see things in the theater
hopefully like something that was that
long you'd have an intermission jack
snyder is a [ __ ]
[ __ ] geeks and gamers had him on and
[ __ ] they they were the ones that
really got the zack snyder cut out
anyone's eyes
first of all i'd like to do i disavow
geeks and gamblers we're not associated
with them guys i just want to stop the
hate
call of a [ __ ] hate group [ __ ]
stupid [ __ ]
i'm [ __ ] i'm glad they did it even
though his original vision for them
for that [ __ ] movie was great that
that's dead dude still [ __ ] prick
all these old hollywood dudes need to go
they're all [ __ ] outdated
they're controlled by somebody somewhere
they're all getting [ __ ]
money political money and these [ __ ]
studios are full of [ __ ]
and they're all gonna go out of business
anyway nobody's nobody's watching their
[ __ ] like they were the shareholders are
gonna [ __ ] fire them
i'm done i'm done that's good i'm glad
to hear it
yeah um so everybody that i'm doing yeah
um no what i was gonna say is that it's
okay so it's wednesday night
now if you're a patron uh tomorrow
morning you'll
be able to get early access to our movie
retrospective like i said we had to do a
backup
because of the situation with what
happened with old boy which was the
movie that won the patreon poll this
week
so i put up a um i put up a review that
we did of audrey rose because that was
one that we watched
so you'll be able to see that one
however i do think my copy of old boy is
going to be here tomorrow or friday
so we should be able to have a review of
that up i'm thinking by
at least saturday we should be able to
have that up because if it comes
friday we can watch it like friday night
or
no i guess we can't watch a friday night
because we're doing the show but we can
watch it like saturday afternoon i'll
like do a review of it
and then i can upload it so i'm kind of
hoping like before the weekend is over
like the review of old boys should be up
because i think the movie is coming
before then
so don't fret but you will have
a couple of movie reviews this week just
because like i said i had to do a backup
because i didn't know if i'd be able to
access that movie
so i guess we're going to like go now
because i'm afraid that the shit's gonna
crash my youtube
crashed a long time ago yeah i can't
even see anybody's chat anymore and it's
like
they're all doing good yeah we did get a
um oh we did a super chat right there
yeah g3 it's fine and it just says
thanks with a little thank you very much
gadgey3 um yeah so you know
sorry everybody t says she's gonna watch
uh [ __ ] empty man again
he's an empty man yeah the empty man
empty man like i said we didn't talk i
put i kind of put that in the title
because like i said i never know what
we're going to talk about on these so i
have to put some in the title
um but yeah you should go see that i
kind of feel like
she's seen it before she's gonna watch a
second yeah like i said it's it's good
because it's better to go into it not
really knowing that much
about it um it it kind of goes in some
interesting directions that you're not
going to expect i mean at least i didn't
expect it to go in those directions
danny mentioned some [ __ ] i want to i
want to mention
something we were talking about ufos
earlier and he's bringing the ufo
subject back up yeah there you go
look this is something that another
thing that adds to the fact that the
phoenix lights was [ __ ] true daddy
mentions it right here
kurt russell was one of the very first
witnesses of the [ __ ] females yeah i
remember somebody saying that i wanted
it he didn't know what it was it started
a distance he reported it and logged it
in called the [ __ ] tower he said he
saw a group of lights over there
you imagine how awesome that would have
been to be like the dispatcher and be
like hey this is
russell and i just saw yeah
of course crustal flies [ __ ]
airplanes man he [ __ ] flies airplanes
and he's
flying around his little [ __ ]
propeller plane but he saw something he
said it looked strange
it was big and it was just he didn't
know what it was i love that right and
he called him in he says there's some
lights out there and the [ __ ] tower
was like
we don't see anything on the radar he
says i see him well he's like well i
think i don't know yes
i see it it's over there okay thank you
and then
and thank you kurt russell thank you
kurt russell and that was
that was the phoenix lights yeah
but like you said he didn't know that's
a leader yeah t says so many people saw
the face
and they all called into [ __ ] 9-1-1
all the same time as it went over
yeah that's the one thing that kind of
makes me feel like well i'm not saying
that it was necessarily extraterrestrial
but
there was obviously something there
because a lot of people
you know that didn't know about one
another like called in about it as it
moved
too many people saw it and it did change
the formation a couple times the numbers
of the lights and it was
whatever it was it was cloaked because
they said they could see we're going to
do a show on this one
about it and some people were out of the
neighborhood
out in the neighborhood you know and the
dude swore up and down it went over his
house he said it was over a mile
wingspan it was flying pretty low and he
says it was an extraterrestrial craft
he's just like it was
then the the governor five simonton came
out he didn't he
later on he says yeah i saw it and he
said he thought it was an
extraterrestrial crafts that was big
and then the dude who saw it fly over
his house the famous witness kind of
pudgy guy
chubby guy he went that [ __ ] is lying
he he didn't see it
he didn't see it it's [ __ ] funny
since i saw it he didn't see it
and he had reasons why i don't remember
what his reasons were
but he thought five simonton was was
trying to lie
and join the crowd but he didn't think
he saw he said the time was wrong
the time in which he claims to have seen
it he couldn't have been
and the way he described it or something
he said he said he didn't see it
you were full [ __ ] fight it was ufo
[ __ ] fight men
from the biggest [ __ ] of them all men
are the biggest [ __ ] i think that's
something
they are you don't have the authority to
say that though you're you're a woman
what do you mean i don't have that only
a man can call other men a [ __ ] in the
biggest [ __ ]
i don't like that women get involved in
that [ __ ] all the men are the men are
the biggest business
well hold on you're out you're stepping
outside stepping outside the territory
yeah but here's the thing this is going
back to what we were doing sexism
well no this is what we were going back
earlier about like how
we're joking we were always joking about
like how like on a haunting for example
like
that she underscores that [ __ ] yeah
right um we're like
see i'm telling you we're just we're
speaking from our personal experience
so when you like [ __ ] on that you're
saying you're essentially doing what the
dude on a haunting is doing and saying
women don't know how
women don't know how things lenses work
or they don't know how reality works
or they don't know how their own
perceptions work you're questioning our
perception
women don't know what grossly from my
perception i'm not saying that
everyone's perception is like this but
from my perception all the dudes that
i've known i have a couple of brothers
i have like you know i've had many male
friends
dudes are bigger [ __ ] generally than
women are t says yes jenny
yes they are yeah women don't know what
ghosts look like they don't know how to
see ghosts
they don't know how to see ufos women
don't know
we don't do we don't know how to do they
don't know how we're completely women
don't know how to witness
we're completely useless and stupid we
don't know how
anything works it's [ __ ] we need
everything explained
we did everything explained to us by a
man obviously because
you know i'm just you know we just
wouldn't know what to do otherwise you
know i'm playing
i mean otherwise we would just lay down
that never
happens in real life though if you told
me you saw some weird [ __ ]
i'd go really i mean i'm not like that
if you better be like that because if i
told you like name one time i did that
you know
well i'm just saying that it's like if
you know how rational i am
so if i saw some weird [ __ ] and i told
you and i was scared and i thought
[ __ ] yeah yeah you know that shit's for
real because i don't play
well you said you heard that doorbell
ring in the middle of the night and i
wasn't too sure
but well you didn't believe me at first
yeah but the thing i thought you were
asleep though i thought you were asleep
no
well what happened well here's what
happened with that i heard the doorbell
and i was willing and i was like okay
i'm pretty sure i was awake and i'm
pretty sure i heard that
but i said to myself
i'm willing to admit that maybe i
imagined it maybe i dreamed it
so i just laid there 30 seconds later
the doorbell rang again
and then i woke you up yeah because i
wasn't sure the first time
i mean i was sure but i was willing to
when she told me what's going on i was
kind of [ __ ] spooked
i said no i heard it again i was naked
and [ __ ] i [ __ ] grabbed again
i grabbed down pistol went out there and
tried to figure looking and i was
[ __ ] being all tactical
i didn't walk up to the door i was
trying to look out yeah he was going
around the side
i was keeping in the darkness trying to
i wouldn't have woke you up otherwise
seriously
if it hadn't rung again yeah i wouldn't
have woke you up and then a few days
later the goddamn [ __ ]
the the the the the garage door opened
that was weird well and a few days later
too the door the back patio
was open in a castle by itself yeah with
that
during that poltergeist yeah with with
the um
what do you call it the yeah that lock
when it's locked
and it was open yeah well it wasn't just
locked it was dead bolted
dead bolted deadbolt was still and it
was still out
but it was open and we we never opened
that never opened that door
i got up to go to work everyone else was
still asleep you were still asleep it
was weird
all the cats were asleep my hair kind of
stood up yeah
it was creepy and the cats were sitting
there watching it
yeah i called you you got that back door
you're like no and i said nope hey and i
was just like how the [ __ ] did that open
yep it was still locked telling you some
weird [ __ ] crazy
yeah all right is it still going because
it's gone
all right so uh okay mine came back this
was like [ __ ] i'm glad it didn't like
go out completely
just because it was yeah my shit's doing
all kind of crazy [ __ ]
but we've been almost three hours that's
good i'm glad i didn't like turn the
[ __ ] off because it did actually come
back after a while we were buffering for
a while
but yeah thanks everybody for dropping
by thanks everybody that donated
what she just says she quotes me i'm not
like that
says the dude that is like that
you are though
there's a [ __ ] that don't even know you
and they're just like they call in that
you are kind of like that yeah and
they're [ __ ] cheering
maybe you don't i'm shutting the show
you don't even you don't even know that
you're like that no more show for you no
more show people
that's it no more show oh a ton more
show
tom i gotcha
he's like i'm taking my drink out
because [ __ ] you guys i'm going home
you going i'm going home yeah we're
already home
so thanks guys for dropping by we will
be back oh [ __ ]
we'll be back on friday evening
talking about killer kids that'll be a
fun show uh but yeah thanks everybody
for dropping by thank you for
everyone who donated and we will see you
on friday night
[Music]
bye